bien bonjour Mesdames et Messieurs chers
collègues la commission d'enquête
chargée d'établir les raisons de la
perte de souveraineté d'indépendance
énergétique de la France a aujourd'hui
l'honneur d'accueillir un ancien Premier
ministre Monsieur Manuel Valls monsieur
le Premier ministre c'est un honneur
pour notre commission d'enquête de
pouvoir échanger avec vous sur une
question stratégique celle de la
souveraineté et de l'impemment
énergétique de la France au cours de
l'exercice de vos fonctions de Premier
ministre des décisions importantes ont
été prises au niveau national européen
et international la loi de 2015 sur la
transition énergétique et pour la
croissance verte les paquets énergies
climat successifs la Conférence des
Nations Unies sur le climat à Paris
c'est également en cours de vos
fonctions qui ont été nommées diverses
personnalités Monsieur François Brotte à
la présidence du directoire de RTE
Monsieur Daniel ververde au CEA monsieur
Jean-Bernard Lévy à la présidence d'EDF
que nous avons tous les trois entendus
monsieur Yves Brechet ancien au
commissaire à l'énergie atomique à par
ailleurs fait part de son expérience
lorsqu'il était au commissaire de 2012 à
certaines décisions et certaines
nominations ont révélé de la se sont
révéler de la compétence du Président de
la République lequel avait pris
l'engagement de réduire à 50% en 2025 la
part du nucléaire dans la production
électrique nous cherchons au sein de
cette commission à démêler
le processus non pas en responsabilité
mais bien le dialogue politique ou
administratif qui a pu se construire
pour mettre en oeuvre les décisions qui
aujourd'hui influent largement la
filière industrielle énergétique et qui
sont qui est chargé de garantir
l'indépendance ou la souveraineté de
notre de notre pays
je ne vais pas être plus long votre
analyse nous sera précieuse et je vais
sans plus tarder vous laisser la parole
pour un propos liminaire avant cela et
en vertu de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance
du 17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires il me revient de vous
demander de bien vouloir prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité et
rien que la vérité en conséquence de
quoi je vous invite à bien vouloir lever
la main droite et dire je le jure le
jure monsieur le Premier ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs c'est
pour moi aussi un honneur d'être
auditionné par votre commission et de
revenir quelques instants à l'Assemblée
nationale
l'institution et une maison
qui m'est cher je le ferai je l'espère
cette audition le mènerait avec avec
modestie parce qu'il s'agit d'une
matière extrêmement
complexe vous la jugez je crois que vous
avez raison sur le sur le temps avec les
nécessaires adaptations j'y reviendrai
qui se sont imposées je rajouterais
aussi que je suis un patriote et je
pense que les enjeux du nucléaire sont
fondamentaux et vitaux pour notre pays
et qu'il demande du consensus mais en
tout cas j'imagine que c'est le but de
vos travaux
d'éclairer non seulement le passé mais
mais le présent et surtout l'avenir
[Musique]
je vais essayer de répondre à un certain
de questions vous en avez évoqué aussi
et puis évidemment nous y reviendrons
autant que nécessaire à travers vos
questions
quelques mots sur
au fond l'appréciation que je peux
porter sur la situation énergétique
actuelle de la France
et sur son évolution même si je ne suis
plus responsabilité depuis
2016 et que j'ai quitté l'Assemblée
nationale en 2018 la fourniture
d'énergie je vous apprends rien repose
sur un système des fournisseurs des
types d'énergie des infrastructures des
opérateurs qui s'inscrivent dans le
temps long
et qui ne changent pas du jour au
lendemain
la situation générale et je ne parle pas
du contexte actuel
géopolitique et de ses conséquences la
situation générale d'aujourd'hui
est peu différente structurellement de
celle que nous connaissions il y a 5 ans
ou même 10 ans une majorité de notre
énergie et d'origine fossile en
particulier à destination du transport
du logement et de l'industrie cette
situation évidemment évolue
progressivement
la guerre en Ukraine nous fait également
accélérer la réduction des énergies
fossiles là des questions qu'elle pose à
notre pays mais à l'ensemble des pays de
l'Union européenne
le système électrique lui est un cas à
part il est plus complexe là aussi je ne
vous apprends rien et c'est un marché
complètement européen il est déjà très
décarbonés en France et il a été mis en
tension forte par le double effet de la
fermeture du
robinet de gaz russe
qui alimente une bonne partie qui
alimentait une bonne partie des
centrales électriques allemandes et de
la baisse de disponibilité du parc
nucléaire français ces deux facteurs
sont indépendants et ce sont cumulés
avec pour conséquence de nous faire
passer assez près de problèmes
d'approvisionnement ponctuel à présent
en l'état des informations qui sont les
miennes je note que les réserves de gaz
sont constituées et que la disponibilité
du parc nucléaire cette amélioré
concernant l'état de disponibilité du
parc nucléaire
je crois toujours modistement qu'il ne
faut pas inverser les causalités depuis
50 ans nous faisons confiance au
nucléaire cette confiance repose sur une
fiabilité remarquable que je veux
défendre
un bilan extrêmement positif au fond
depuis que nous disposons de
l'électricité d'électricité nucléaire
cette confiance repose sur le fait que
le pays ne prend aucun risque en termes
de sécurité de sûreté du parc cette
absence de risque peut avoir pour
conséquence que nous préférions
ponctuellement prendre des risques
d'approvisionnement que les risques
techniques c'est ce qui s'est passé
lorsque des cas de corrosion sous
contrainte sur une partie du parc que
sont révélées c'est aussi ce qui s'est
passé en 2016
lorsqu'il a été constaté j'y reviendrai
des concentrations anormales de carbone
dans les générateurs de vapeur d'une
vingtaine de réacteurs
le parc a rencontré des problèmes
génériques donc en 2015-2016 et en 2021
2022 et les autorités de sûreté sont là
pour les surveiller elles le font ce
sont des problèmes qui se résolvent
comme en ce moment
quand on gouverne
s'y prépare le mieux possible
on n'aime pas a priori que des problèmes
apparaissent s'en passeraient mais c'est
comme ça ils apparaissent
et il est évident que ceux qui ont en
charge la responsabilité le destin du
pays font face aujourd'hui des défis
considérables
le premier nous le connaissions déjà
c'est celui du réchauffement climatique
deuxième ce sont les conséquences du
conflit en Ukraine troisième
c'est une de ses conséquences le coût de
l'énergie et puis il y a le défi du
renouvellement du parc nucléaire
et de comment à travers notamment le
discours du président de la République
en février 2022
nous traçons cette voie et quels sont
les moyens que nous ne donnons pour
arriver aux objectifs
à signer
l'important en tout cas
c'est d'aller de l'avant de garder la
capacité de résoudre et d'avancer non
pas d'un point de vue politique
seulement mais aussi d'un point de vue
technique et technologique c'est là où
le politique doit être modeste
moi parce que je me méfie toujours du
déclinisme du catastrophisme je dirais
mais peut-être que je m'avance trop que
la situation d'aujourd'hui n'est pas si
mauvaise si on la compare à celle
d'autres pays qui n'ont pas de source
d'électricité des carbonées et je
regarde toujours avec beaucoup d'intérêt
les défis qui sont ceux par exemple de
l'Allemagne qui est confronté évidemment
à des choix financiers politiques
sociaux énergétique
colossale les moyens ne fera pas sans
doute le choix du retour au nucléaire
mais elle est confrontée bien sûr assez
assez défis et je ne doute pas de ce
point de vue là que vos travaux seront
utiles
quel était l'état de la filière
nucléaire en France
quand j'ai pris mes fonctions
le premier avril 2014 après deux années
passées au ministère de l'Intérieur et
qu'elles ont été au fond ces évolutions
pendant
ce mandat cette responsabilité
l'état de la filière n'était pas
tellement différent d'aujourd'hui
mais le contexte politique
au sens le plus noble du terme l'été
et je veux insister parce que la mémoire
a tendance à s'effacer
Fukushima l'accident au Japon était
encore récent avait marqué les opinions
2011 2012 l'Allemagne venait de décider
de renoncer au nucléaire avec des
conséquences techniques et industrielles
pour nous
Areva a mal
et flamant ville 3
avait des retards substantiels
et puis nous avions aussi l'objectif
des signets assignés par le Président de
la République
au gouvernement de bien préparer la Coop
21 la conférence de Paris c'est vrai que
il y avait un accord de gouvernement en
tout cas un accord parlementaire avec
les écologistes avec les Verts qui ont
quitté d'ailleurs le gouvernement des
manominations pas sur ce sujet là qui
n'était pas favorable au nucléaire nous
leur avions proposé parce que moi je
suis toujours transparent pour qu'il
reste au gouvernement qu'ils assument
éventuellement cette tâche au ministère
de l'énergie ou ou de l'écologie
ils ne l'ont pas fait le président de la
République lui je vous apprends rien
c'est même des sujets de que vous avez
abordés monsieur le Président c'était
engagé sur la limitation à 50% d'une
claire dans la production électrique et
sur la fermeture des réacteurs de
façades
dans ce contexte nous sommes donnés
comme objectif de soutenir la filière
nucléaire sans ambiguïté je parle mon
gouvernement
et qu'il n'y ait aucune je veux insister
là-dessus orientation irréversible prise
en dehors de la fermeture du de
fasenheim décision politique on est
reviendra et qui était aussi un enjeu
vous savez bien monsieur le Président
bonjour on va l'appeler diplomatique
avec avec l'Allemagne en tout cas sujet
de préoccupation aussi pour les
autorités allemandes qui n'avaient pas
manqué de nous la transmettre à travers
la chancelière Merkel
la filière a tenu son rang le parc
nucléaire un fourni trois quarts de son
électricité au pays et nous avons opéré
je reviendrai bien sûr le sauvetage
d'Areva
nommé des patrons de qualité
vous l'avez évoqué à la tête de def
ramato mais Areva au-delà des noms vous
avez cités mais les vies Fontana Varin
puis organiser avec les ministres en
charge la reprise par EDF de Framatome
et la nationalisation des autres parties
d'Areva aujourd'hui mais vous avez sans
doute vous un œil plus aigu que le mien
tous les acteurs fonctionnent j'imagine
avec leur défi financiers technologique
au sein d'une filière dynamique et qui
recrute
le parc est vieillissant donc il n'est
pas anormal qu'il y ait davantage de
maintenance c'était vrai hier c'est vrai
aujourd'hui
à faire de maintenant ça accomplir à
faire au fil du temps nous avons par
ailleurs je l'ai rappelé des autorités
de sûreté qui sont probablement parmi
les plus exigeantes du monde
cela se traduit logiquement par une
baisse de disponibilité et donc une
baisse de la production annuelle mais
elle doit remonter
par contre
c'est une filière qui manquait de
projets neuf pour entretenir la
compétence des ingénieurs et techniciens
au meilleur niveau
et qui en manque toujours
le dernier réacteur de production
électrique a été mise en service dans
les années 90
voilà
premier point sur sur cette étape sur
sur ce que j'ai trouvé je succédais à
Jean-Marc Ayrault on était déjà dans un
quinquennat j'étais ministre de
l'Intérieur donc j'assume évidemment
tout ce qui a été fait pendant pendant
ces 5 ans quelle a été la stratégie
qu'elles ont été les principales
décisions
prises en matière énergétique et
pourquoi elles ont été prises et que ça
mettait leur fondement
nous étions
et j'étais favorable au nucléaire
reviendra sur le débat avant la
présidentielle
et je rajoute parce que c'est un élément
qui est lié même pas dans votre
j'imagine c'est un sujet qu'on abordez
pas en tout cas directement nous étions
aussi évidemment favorable savions quel
était le lien avec le nucléaire civil à
la notre dissuasion
nucléaire j'ai eu moi très vite
d'ailleurs l'occasion de m'exprimer sur
ces questions là
dans le cadre d'un discours sur la
transition énergétique au Bourget le 15
octobre 2014 donc quelques mois après ma
nomination pour insister que le
nucléaire c'est pour notre pays
une filière stratégique
et j'ai rappelé aussi les enjeux de
cette filière ce que représentait en
termes de chiffre d'affaires 46
milliards d'euros les entreprises de
toute taille des pme-nivant les grands
groupes qui forment un tissu industriel
très compétitif et reconnu à l'étranger
et rappeler que ces entreprises qui
interviennent sur les marchés des
centrales clés en main du remplacement
des pièces de l'entretien exportent et
emploi directement ou indirectement à
l'époque de 120 000 salariés j'avais
visité d'ailleurs le site Areva avant
l'été au Creusot et j'insistais sur le
fait que je me cite pardon le nucléaire
c'est pour la France un facteur
d'indépendance et de puissance
industrielle économique diplomatique
militaire c'est un atout majeur pour le
présent et pour l'avenir et j'ai rappelé
quels étaient évidemment les enjeux pour
nous
en dehors de l'Union Européenne aussi
notamment en Chine puisque la
concurrence c'était intensifiée avec de
nombreux pays donc l'idée était de mieux
structurer la filière nucléaire de lui
donner de la visibilité à l'étranger
c'est important j'ai un système pour
l'autre balance commerciale et pour nos
emplois mais aussi également pour notre
recherche d'innovation et des progrès
techniques que nous devons accomplir et
je veux insister là-dessus
de nombreuses décisions ont été prises
pour préserver la filière nous
ironsiendrons sans doute je veux pas
manger mon propos un sauver les
composantes d'Areva en 2015-2016 2
lancer le projet de deux paires à une
quel point c'est à l'été 2016 3 lancer
le projet de SMS petit réacteur
modulaire vous le savez parfaitement 4
actées dans un texte de loi le lancement
du projet de stockage géologique des
déchets du parc nucléaire à sigeo
d'abord pas la loi et ensuite suite un
protocole du Conseil constitutionnel à
travers une proposition de loi dites
Longuet au Sénat de 2016 5 soutenir le
projet de réacteurs de recherche rovitz
successeur du réacteur
Osiris qui sert à produire des
particules pour la physique nucléaire et
à tester les comportements des matériaux
sous irrigations des Osiris mais en 2005
c'est un réacteur ancien dont les normes
de construction semble-t-il ne
correspondait plus au standard de sûreté
nécessaire
si soutenir le projet d'exportation du
concept d'usine de lag en Chine et je me
suis d'ailleurs
rendu a Pékin début 2015 rencontrer et
le président chez shimping et
l'homologue Premier ministre pour
promouvoir ce projet
important de ce déplacement
6 parmi les projets du CEA nous avons
également soutenu le lancement des
études très luminaires du prototype
Astrid 7 a été acté pendant cette
période évidemment c'était de la
responsabilité d'EDF le plan de grands
carénage des mises en oeuvre après il
s'agissait de la vague d'investissement
indispensable pour le parc nucléaire
afin de lui permettre d'envisager de
dépasser la quatrième visite
décennale et ce projet cette idée était
évidemment activement soutenue par
président de la République et par mon
gouvernement
chez un projet autour de 50 milliards
d'euros j'imagine qu'il y a eu des des
évolutions nous pourrons j'imagine
revenir sur ces sur ces sur ces sujets
notamment sur six géo une quelpaint et
la faillite d'avare
les plus les plus complexes que j'ai eu
à traiter et on y a consacré évidemment
beaucoup beaucoup de temps j'évoque
uniquement un point nous reviendrons sur
ces si vous le souhaitez évidemment sur
ces sujets
sur le passage de l'hiver 2016-2017
parce que là la mémoire c'est effacée on
l'a oublié mais nous avons connu une
situation analogue à celle de ces
dernières semaines il y a 6 ans des
réacteurs avaient été mis à l'arrêt à la
demande de l'ASN pour des questions
d'accumulation de carbone dans certaines
pièces métalliques sous pression des
réunions de régulière suivi ont été
organisés à
Matignon à l'automne avec EDF pour
évaluer les risques de défaillance
pendant l'hiver et finalement
comme cette fois
les choses se sont plutôt
bien bien passé
donc je veux uniquement évoquer ce
point-là je poursuis à propos de la
de la stratégie et des principales
décisions que nous avons prises alors
que j'étais Premier ministre
avec la loi de transition énergétique au
fond nous cherchions à répondre c'est
des sujets là aussi complexes au retard
je crois il faut l'admettre je crois que
Jean-Louis Borloo vouloir vous l'avez
dit pris par la France sur la question
des énergies renouvelables alors que
sous le quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy
qui avait eu une volonté affirmée dès le
début avec ce même jeu en Louis Barlow
qui occupait cette responsabilité de
ministres de l'écologie
nous avons créé plusieurs outils
Royal elle vous le rappellera bien mieux
que moi le chèque énergie pour protéger
les précaires la PPE et la SNBC
c'est-à-dire les outils de programmation
tactiques et stratégiques c'est
important de le de le faire à quelques
mois de la de la COP 21 sur les
concessions hydroélectriques un mot nous
étions pressés par la Commission
européenne de les ouvrir à la
concurrence et nous voulions surtout les
assurer qu'elle continue à tenir leur
rang nous avions imaginé des
alternatives d'ailleurs à la mise en
concurrence pour en garder le contrôle
nous avons aussi lancé dispositifs de
protection des
industriels énergo intensifs pour qu'il
y ait une visibilité et l'accès à de
l'énergie à bon marché nous avons
accéléré c'est toujours un sujet
sur la rénovation thermique des
logements du bâtiment avec un crédit
d'impôt transition écologique créé en
2014 confirmé et renforcé ensuite devenu
aujourd'hui ma prime rénove avec 7
millions de bornes électriques en 2030
tout ça a été dans la loi de 2015 donc
la loi de transition énergétique je veux
pas m'y attarder comme son nom
l'indiquait se donner pour objectif que
la France change de braquet pardon et de
familier en matière d'énergie
renouvelable
il y avait une volonté partagée au sein
du gouvernement pour aller en ce sens et
à titre personnel j'étais évidemment
très favorable d'ailleurs
j'ai fait de nombreux déplacements sur
ce sujet et le point de vue qui était
défendu
c'était que la part du nucléaire était à
terme sans doute trop grande pour ne pas
présenter des risques de toute nature
qu'il fallait la réduire en tout cas
qu'il y ait un véritable appel d'air
vers l'éolien et le photovoltaïque
c'était ça le principe et la question ce
n'était pas tant le niveau de 50% que la
direction que l'on souhaitait prendre
pour ouvrir à d'autres sources non
carbonées que le nucléaire et
l'hydroélectrique
à l'époque latin de l'objectif des 50%
je pense que c'est là où il y a un débat
sans doute un objectif très ambitieux
reposer sur le développement rapide des
énergies renouvelables et sur une
capacité d'export de la production
électrique superflue il s'agissait pas
de faire baisser de façon artificielle
la production nucléaire mais bien de se
tourner vers un cap différent par moyen
ou long terme alors sur les 50% je crois
qu'il faut il faut être clair
il y avait un accord politique je veux
revenir il y a eu
un accord qui a été formulé
avant l'été ou pendant l'été 2011 moi
j'étais pas membre de la direction du
Parti socialiste donc je n'ai pas
participé entre la première secrétaire
de l'époque madame Martin Aubry et les
écologistes pour préparer et la
présidentielle et les élections
législatives il y avait un accord
programmatique et un accord
électoral et cet accord était très
ambitieux sur les sujets que nous
évoquons avec sans doute des ambiguïtés
de langage
sorti programmée du nucléaire ou sortie
programmée du tout nucléaire c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose d'où ensuite
l'apparition du chiffre des
50%. le débat a eu lieu pendant les
primaires et je reviens sur le contexte
l'accident au Japon
le climat
créé par le retrait de l'Allemagne les
pressions européennes
une opinion toujours adhérée
au nucléaire mais qui était sans doute
plus sceptique à ce à ce moment-là et
sans doute aussi des formes
d'emballement dans le débat internes
d'une formation politique à l'occasion
des primaires et nous avons tous
participé moi aussi je me suis
d'ailleurs rendu très jeune candidat à
cette primaire mon score était
remarquable j'ai fait 6% mais ça ouvert
une carrière politique spectaculaire
vendu à facenheim la discussion avec les
syndicats a été rudes mais forcément
intéressant mais la plupart des
candidats à la primaire
en tout cas les principaux François
Hollande Martin Aubry ensuite
favorables assez objectif mais nous
n'étions pas favorables au contenu de
l'accord avec avec
les verres c'est pour cela mais vous le
dira mieux que moi si il vient
s'exprimer devant vous le candidat
François Hollande dans son projet
c'en est tenu au-delà des objectifs en
termes d'énergie renouvelables au 50%
pour aller vite et je crois à la
fermeture des deux réacteurs de de
façonnerie
alors que dans la corde PSVR il y avait
la fermeture progressive de 24 réacteurs
sur 58 le chiffre je ne suis pas
responsable donc je ne sais pas pourquoi
on est arrivé à cela mais en fait
c'était l'idée qui circulait c'est bien
on avait pris les centrales ou les
réacteurs les plus les plus les plus les
plus anciens il y a eu d'ailleurs
un incident politique autour d'une
quatrième mesure de l'accord
qui était la démobilisation de la
filière du MOX
ce mélange d'oxyde d'uranium et
plutonium qui permet de recycler en
partie le combustible d'uranium déjà
utilisé et le candidat à François
Hollande avec
mon soutien et celui de celui qui était
pas parole de la campagne Bernard
Cazeneuve
année à ce qu'on retire ce point
d'ailleurs
aussi n'est pas parole de cette campagne
j'avais dit on n'arrêtera pas le
nucléaire donc pas non plus le MOX ni
l'usine de La Hague
pendant la campagne électorale donc
voilà pour le contexte je rappelle
si ça a beaucoup d'intérêt que je le
fasse dans ce propos liminaire je le
fais
que ce sujet là était un débat de la
campagne présidentielle
président de la République
surtout pour qui j'ai de respect et
estime mais on a fait un sujet de de
campagne j'ai noté d'ailleurs qui
n'avaient qu'il avait tenu au moins
trois réunions publiques très
importantes sur ce sujet là une pierre
la trigastin en novembre une autre à
face à Naïm en février 2012 et une autre
à Saint-Laurent-des-Eaux en mars parce
que c'était c'était un des sujets
importants d'ailleurs même dans la
campagne disons est-ce que ce sont des
rencontres du président de la République
ou des meetings les deux sans doute mais
c'est le jeu il est pas le seul à avoir
fait ça avant et et après bon donc le
sujet est venu moi je ne peux
qu'exprimer qu'un regrette d'ailleurs à
ce moment-là c'est que je crois que sur
ce sujet là j'ai insiste les grandes
forces politiques en tout cas celles qui
gouvernait depuis longtemps à l'époque
des choses ont changé depuis
ce soit pas davantage accordé sur ce
sujet là qui avait toujours fait l'objet
de
contexte parce que au-delà des choix qui
ont été faits à la fin de la quatrième
République et au début de la 5e au-delà
du plan Messmer
les années 80-90 ont été marqués par
renforcement impressionnant d'autre part
que nucléaire des choix des
gouvernements de François Mitterrand
ensuite de de Jacques Chirac d'ailleurs
avec la particularité que souvent le
début des quinquennats ou les septennats
à l'époque
tous mais se passer par l'abandon d'un
projet
pour la gauche en 81 beaucoup d'ici
n'était pas né vous lisez les histoires
comme moi moi j'étais né
actif déjà commencé par la fermeture de
Plogoff et l'abandon ensuite mais vous
l'avez évoqué hier une super Phoenix
même si cela a duré un certain temps
comme je l'ai écrit une fois et je peux
pas échapper à la formule l'une des
choses qui m'a toujours
c'est pour le rapporteur mais nous le
signalent pas qui m'a fait sourire mon
fort intérieur c'est que le président
Macron c'est ça la continuité c'est
trouver à mettre en oeuvre une décision
qui avait été négociée entre Martine
Aubry et les Verts
je lis pour pour égayer un tout petit
peu là la Commission comme pourquoi je
dis ça et je redeviens sérieux c'est
parce que les les
choix dans ce domaine là et vous vous
connaissez tous les deux d'autres aussi
ces sujets là nécessitent évidemment
beaucoup beaucoup de temps nous y
reviendrons si
si vous voulez
et nous le voyons nous l'avons bien vu
en 2010
par rapport à cet objectif qui avait
fait l'objet de débat
au Sénat je vais en dire un mot
2000 pardon en 2018 Nicolas Hulot a
décalé de 10 ans l'objectif des 50% et
tous ces éléments de plafond vient
d'être supprimés aujourd'hui par le par
le par le Sénat
pendant la discussion au Parlement de la
loi
il y a eu des tentatives de rendre plus
difficiles le dépassement de durée
au-delà de 40 ans de la durée de vie des
centrales
je veux rappeler que ce point a été
constamment refusé par mon gouvernement
et notamment par la voie de la ministre
Ségolène Royal que davantage de pouvoirs
ont été donnés à la SN
et c'est la manière que nous avions
choisi pour consolider dans le sens de
ce que vous disais il y a un instant le
consensus national sur le nucléaire
quel est l'impact de la loi sur la
filière nucléaire imagine qu'il y a des
points de vue différents
moi je crois qu'il faut distinguer le
parc en exploitation et les projets
neufs et concernant les projets neufs là
aussi
j'ai insiste comme je l'ai fait sur
Areva
nous avions plusieurs facteurs qui
pouvaient nuire à l'attractivité
Fukushima
des difficultés de construction
sérieuses ou L3 bien sûr et flamant
ville 3
et une opinion
les choses ont changé depuis en tout cas
ne pouvait marquer un certain
scepticisme
comment les conséquences des arbitrages
que je viens d'évoquer ont-elles été
appréhendées d'abord concernant la
sécurité d'approvisionnement en énergie
et des besoins d'investir dans le réseau
électrique je vais pas être long
à aucun moment il n'a été envisagé que
les investissements dans le réseau ou la
sécurité d'approvisionnement puisse être
dégradée du fait de la loi
la sécurité d'approvisionnement
prédominait sur tous les autres sujets à
aucun moment je n'étais sollicité pour
prendre des décisions mettant en jeu la
sécurité d'approvisionnement par rapport
à la nature du paradigme électrique
national il n'y avait il n'y a eu aucune
alerte de la part de RTE sur la
production électrique à ce moment-là
voilà pointe à l'époque d'ailleurs à
l'époque François brode l'a rappelé
aussi devant votre commission la France
exportait son électricité et assez
largement
je veux insister sur ce point là
pour consolider le système de production
électrique nous avons aussi mis en
oeuvre ce qu'on appelle le mécanisme de
capacité qui oblige les fournisseurs
d'électricité à s'assurer qu'ils ont
accès à la production d'énergie
suffisante pour servir leurs clients et
qui assure que les centrales disponibles
sont rendus elles-mêmes disponibles pour
cela c'est une mesure de protection de
la sécurité d'approvisionnement elle a
été conçue en 2015-2016 elle est
opérationnelle depuis le 1er janvier
concernant le placement le plafonnement
pardon relatif au nucléaire
il y a eu deux décisions de limitation
une que je pourrais appeler ferme
mordante
qui a créé des débats qui encore la
limitation à 63,2 gigawatts nucléaire
installé qui visait à fermer à forcée
pendant la fermeture de Fessenheim et
une qui était programmatique les 50% au
2025 cet objectif visait à cadrer
les exercices de programmation y compris
bien sûr les enjeux de sécurité
d'approvisionnement il y a eu bien sûr
aussi le sujet de la durée de vie des
réacteurs les premiers s'approchaient de
leur fin de vie et on n'avait pas
forcément
sans doute les techniciens oui mais les
choses ont beaucoup évolué au cours de
ces dernières années nous n'avions pas
la certitude donc qu'il pouvait être
prolongé au-delà des 40 ans et dans tous
les cas la SN émettait des conditions
exigeantes et c'est bien normal à ceux
prolongement il était donc nécessaire
d'envisager d'autres moyens de
production s'il fallait fermer les
choses ont évoluées parce que à l'époque
on parlait de 40 ans aujourd'hui dans le
débat suite aux décisions qu'une prise
aux États-Unis on parle de 80
le politique il fait face aussi
à ses évolutions technologiques qui au
changement même de ceux qui de ceux qui
les portent
et s'il fallait
envisager d'autres moyens de production
et bien il fallait faire monter aussi en
puissance
les
énergies renouvelables
il n'y avait aucun objectif de fermeture
en dehors des deux tranches
de 900 mégawatts de Fessenheim
il fallait cependant prendre en compte
que certains réacteurs risquaient de
voir fermer mais nous nous sommes
absolument refusés à fixer par la loi
une limite à la durée de vie des des
directs et bien sûr une grande partie
des choix qui étaient faits étaient
conditionnés à l'ouverture de
Flamanville de Flamanville 3
concernant
la fermeture de Fessenheim à l'époque il
nous était parfois reprochés de ne pas
être allé vite vers cela nous avions en
tête que c'est une opération complexe
c'est pour cela qu'elle avait duré
qu'elle a duré délégué interministériels
ont été nommés il y a eu beaucoup de
discussions entre la ministre et EDF
il y avait évidemment un débat
sur le fait que il était discutable
d'arrêter des réacteurs en bon état de
fonctionnement
à l'époque je ne peux pas oublier que
les centrales avaient été au départ
conçus pour une durée de vie de 40 ans
j'y reviens vous avez été construite à
partir de 1971 en service en 1977 il
était normal de prévoir leur arrêt un
horizon plus ou moins proche
l'idée était donc flamant ville 3 sur
mise en place à peu près au même moment
et donc de ne pas se retrouver avec une
baisse de production électrique
pilotable on peut faire le repas
et l'ouverture de Flamanville n'ayant
pas eu lieu encore davantage c'est
encore le cas aujourd'hui
concernant un mot là-dessus des
centrales à charbon nous avions en tête
qu'il fallait les fermer parce que
c'était trop émettrice de CO2 j'ai même
fait des annonces dans ce domaine il en
restait quatre de mémoire
Gardanne Saint-Avold en Moselle d'accord
de mai à Nantes et Le Havre nous
comptions sur les marges qui existaient
dans la production sur les centrales à
gaz sur les effacements sur les
interconnexions pour faire la pointe
c'est nécessaire
en pratique je vais pas me tromper les
centrales n'ont pas été fermées au cours
de ce mandat
malgré la volonté que j'avais émises
concernant la planification nous avons
mis en place deux outils importants la
stratégie nationale bas carbone et la
programmation plus annuelle de l'énergie
je rappelle que l'enjeu c'est que la
France accélère dans le domaine des
honneurs peut-être donc je suis pas
spécialiste de ces sujets là il y a eu
trop de volontarisme dans ce domaine en
tout cas on pensait à atteindre de
nombreux objectifs et on s'est aperçu
que c'était sans doute plus complexe
mais en tout cas je crois que l'objectif
était indispensable et qu'il est
toujours pertinent aujourd'hui je le
je le je le soutenais voilà pour les
éléments que je voulais vous donner dans
une déclaration
préliminaire
moi j'ai une conviction encore une fois
le consensus me paraît nécessaire la
deuxième c'est que le politique doit
être modeste par rapport au choix
technique et technologiques et que
parfois et pas seulement dans ce domaine
là nous sommes amenés à des à des à des
changements du contexte
géopolitique aux questions posées en
termes d'approvisionnement
d'énergie et le choix qui a été fait il
y a un an maintenant par le Président de
la République
de relancer
avec force
la filière nucléaire et se donner des
objectifs en latex mais au-delà de ses
choix
j'ai la conviction je crois que nous
avons la capacité que c'est sur nos
précisément une force nos capacités
technologiques nous pourrons les
atteindre et c'est pour cela que
l'ouverture de flamants en ville est
importante dans ce débat stratégique
parce que nous ne pouvons pas compter
uniquement sur le prolongement des
centrales nucléaires il faut être
capable
d'ouvrir de faire marcher Flamanville
mais aussi de se donner cet objectif de
petits réacteurs entre guillemets qui
permettrait un autre
industrie nucléaire un autre filière
nucléaire et aussi à toute la filière à
toutes les filières liées aux
investissements dans ce secteur à la
recherche
à l'innovation de de faire réunion de la
France à l'export car
la
mon mandat ça s'est passé avant
quinquennat François Hollande était
marqué aussi avec un choc dont je pense
sous-estime les conséquences par l'échec
de des Émirats
arabes unis qui a marqué durablement
l'ensemble des acteurs et qui a fait
comprendre que
la concurrence allait être rude et que
les remises en question étaient
indispensables d'une manière générale je
pense qu'il faut aussi que les grandes
institutions de cette filière soient
capables de se remettre en question pour
pouvoir accompagner les choix du pays
qu'il a appartiennent la fois politique
et surtout au peuple
merci beaucoup monsieur le monsieur le
Premier ministre pour ce propos
liminaire déjà très complet qui
forcément suscite un certain nombre de
questions
j'en aurai une première vraiment sur les
enjeux politiques
50% le 2025 c'est un sujet qui marque
une forme de tournant dans dans la
posture du gouvernement vis-à-vis du
nucléaire du gouvernement au sens du
temps long comme du consensus que vous
avez décrit qui naît dès après la
quatrième République j'ai le sentiment
avec les auditions successives qui est
une forme d'explication apostériori qui
s'est construite sur ce que sont
réellement ces 50%. non c'est un
objectif
de temps long vu de 2012 2025 semble
loin
dans les discussions qui s'installent on
se rend compte que finalement tout le
monde avait quand même déjà une
perception que 2012-2025 c'était une
bonne dizaine d'années et que ça allait
très vite
et surtout du coup j'ai une une
incompréhension de l'explication de ce
que sont ces 50%
encore une fois les choix politiques
c'est pas quelque chose qui me dérange
en fait tous de la politique mais c'est
de bien comprendre ce qu'ils sont à
l'époque puisque dans votre exposé
millénaire vous avez vous avez deux fois
parlé d'un d'un volet export en disant
finalement les 50%
c'est une part de la consommation
intérieure d'électricité finale
d'électricité donc on peut on peut
réduire cette part du nucléaire en
exportant une partie de notre nucléaire
au pays voisins c'est une explication
que François broc nous a faite aussi et
en même temps vous venez quasiment de
conclure en expliquant que à l'époque on
était tranquille on avait des marges
d'export et finalement on pouvait rogner
sur ces marges pour mener des politiques
intérieures c'est une contradiction qui
qui semble fragiliser un peu cette
réflexion autour de ce que sont ces 50%
donc je sais pas quelle lecture vous
vous en faites
on est sur une matière en fusion c'est
la politique et donc
forcément il y a des interprétations il
y a des faits
pourquoi le débat est élu aux femmes
vous le savez mieux que moi
[Musique]
le débat a lieu sur les 50% et les
divisions qui ont été prises
évidemment je sais pas bien cet argument
et sur la fermeture
annoncée puis mise en oeuvre des deux
tranches de réacteurs de fassenheim
comme un élément qui affaiblirait qui
aurait affaibli
la filière et à partir de ce moment-là
avec des difficultés pour
recruter les ingénieurs des ouvriers des
soudeurs etc
peut-être
mais je pense que les difficultés la
filière viennent d'avant je dis d'avant
non pas pour mettre en cause nos
prédécesseurs c'est un débat qui ne
m'intéresse pas ou qui m'intéresse plus
n'est pas ce que j'essaie d'être devant
la mesure du possible objectif
je crois qu'il faut jamais nier les
responsabilités si là il y a eu
un affaiblissement il faut pointer mais
alors il faut pointer l'ensemble des
étapes qui ont conduit à des difficultés
pour la filière nucléaire mais c'est le
sens c'est le but de votre de votre de
votre commission ce que je constate
c'est que ce choix a été poursuivi en
tout cas pendant le quinquennat le
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
qui a changé la date
j'essaie de vous répondre le plus
franchement en plus je suis astreint
mais à partir de ce que je connais je
n'ai pas fait moi ce choix
je pense que ce choix est un choix
d'abord politique
il suffit d'ailleurs de regarder
le premier débat de la primaire
enfin septembre 2011 et de l'opposition
entre Martine Aubry et François Hollande
sur ce sujet là pour comprendre que le
choix des 50% est sans doute lié à
la contrainte de l'accord qui qui était
imposée par les par le PS et les Verts
et dont le celui qui allait désigné
candidat à la présidentielle vous les
sortir je parle de François Hollande
deuxièmement
les 50% c'est là où je suis franc je
crois n'était le résultat d'aucune étude
d'impact ou analyse de besoins l'optique
c'est vrai a été politique passé de 3/4
environ
un demi à la moitié la part du nucléaire
dans la consommation électrique avec
dans l'esprit que le que le
développement des énergies renouvelables
étaient peut-être entravé pour certains
par la place du nucléaire comme une zone
de confort et qu'il fallait en quelque
sorte la libérer pour d'autres énergies
je crois que c'était ça la philosophie
pour beaucoup d'ailleurs de spécialistes
avec tous les contextes contradictions
qui existent dans ce domaine là de
pourcentage pour certains pouvaient
paraître
crédible
mais c'est vrai que personne
réellement
dès que vous êtes au gouvernement vous
redonner sérieux
personne n'imaginait fermé 20 réacteurs
en disant
et à partir de ce moment là
tout savait
que 2025 était une date compliquée
mais
personne considérait qu'il fallait
arriver à tout prix à cette date et
qu'il fallait la souplesse nécessaire et
que c'était sans doute trop tôt et
d'ailleurs je vois qui a été fait je
l'ai rappelé tout à l'heure par Nicolas
Hulot à ce moment-là ministre
nommé par Emmanuel Macron paraissait
sage et il est évident que les
bouleversements que nous venons de
connaître depuis un an oblige à une
autre stratégie
il y a eu un homme très important qui a
compté dans les années 80 au sein de la
formation politique qui était la mienne
mais aussi pour le pays qui était Paul
qui laisse
ministre disparu il y a quelques temps
qui était un grand spécialiste de ces
questions et c'est l'un ceux qui a porté
ce projet
dans les années dans les années 80
auprès du président François Mitterrand
pendant sa campagne et par et par et par
la suite donc ma formation politique
était en soi marquée par cela elle était
très favorable ou nucléaire civil comme
comme militaire et donc pendant ce
quinquennat pendant que j'étais en
responsabilité
il y a eu des ambiguïtés
des contradictions peut-être mais en
tout cas nous n'avons jamais
en gouvernant compris que l'objectif des
50% et la fermeture de façadesheim était
une mise en cause du nucléaire bien au
contraire puisque pour le reste dans les
choix pour le pays comme dans les choix
à l'export
nous étions évidemment très allant et
nous étions aussi j'y reviendrai
arc-bouter sur la nécessité de sauver en
tout cas de préserver de renforcer le
mot sauvé et de trop cette filière
nucléaire par rapport à un certain
nombre de difficultés que nous avions
on s'interdira donc dans notre dans
notre rapport de préconiser la fin des
primaires
je ne savais pas que vous aviez cette
compétence
mais c'est un conseil que je vous donne
à titre personnel pour en avoir été
acteur pour en avoir eu des points
positifs et pour en avoir été victime
bien pour revenir un peu sur des choses
plus sérieuses mais qui qui
répondent un peu de cette
de cette disgression humoristique
le sentiment mais c'est difficile de
relire
l'histoire à posteriori et
pour le rapporteur comme pour moi je
crois que nous n'étions pas dans le cœur
du réacteur à ce moment-là bien trop
éloigné d'être capable de l'être
et ce qui semble important c'est de
reposer parfois le contexte et de bien
prendre en compte le contexte dans
lequel les décisions sont prises
le débat sur sur le nucléaire devient
à l'occasion de de votre mandat de
Premier ministre à l'occasion de la
législature un débat politique en tant
que tel s'efface progressivement c'est
le sentiment
le débat sur la question de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement qui semblait quand
même structuré le débat politique sur
les questions d'énergie dans les
décennies précédentes
c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve
finalement dans l'organisation qui est
antérieur à la vôtre
des enjeux politiques dans la définition
des périmètres ministériels et donc dans
la définition des espaces d'arbitrage
interministériel
donc ma question elle est là-dessus
comment est-ce que vous regardez à
posteriori ou et ou dans le contexte
la construction d'un ministère qui mêle
désintérêts qui peuvent être contraires
énergie et environnement qui se
retrouvent finalement avec des
arbitrages ensuite ou la question de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement n'est
peut-être pas suffisamment mise en
évidence à l'occasion de la monter des
arbitrages en réunion interministérielle
je passe ma question est claire
je crois la comprendre
monsieur le Président d'abord j'insiste
sur le fait mais je l'ai fait tout à
l'heure donc je peux pas être redondant
sur le fait que pour nous
la sécurité d'approvisionnement
était une priorité
et n'a jamais été cette priorité effacée
au détriment d'autres d'autres sujets je
les je l'ai rappelé il est vrai que nous
n'avions pas les mêmes difficultés que
nous avons connues après
et que le fait que la France exporte
largement son électricité était un
élément qui nous permettait d'être
volontariste sur ces sur ces sur ces
sujets là
le choix qui est fait
par le président Hollande
partager
évidemment par son premier ministre de
nommer une personnalité forte à la tête
de ce ministère choix qui avait été fait
avant
par exemple par le président Nicolas
Sarkozy en nommant Jean-Louis Bordeaux
qui était personnalité
forte remarquable qui avait été sans
doute le meilleur ministre de la
politique de la ville que ce pays est
connu
donc il y avait une confiance pour mener
cela mais sur ces sujets là qui était
prioritaire dans l'esprit des Français
peut-être pas avec encore les mêmes
préoccupations aujourd'hui sur la
question du réchauffement
climatique si vous voulez aussi un signe
fort par rapport à l'opinion
je le signale
pas plus que cela politique mais
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure les vers
venaient de quitter le gouvernement donc
il s'agissait de montrer que sur
ceux qui imaginent que sont les Verts
qui ont incarnent mieux que d'autres
l'écologie ce qui est un autre débat en
tout cas le président de la République
moi-même avion comme souci que cette
priorité soit toujours
affirmée à travers celle qui avait été
la candidate de la gauche en tout cas du
Parti socialiste en 2007 quelques années
auparavant
dans ce ministère
dans n'importe quel gouvernement et dans
la structure
d'un gouvernement et de l'État en tout
cas des administrations publiques il y a
toujours eu ces contradictions entre les
vitres la priorité à l'écologie et la
priorité à l'industrie
et pas uniquement sur les questions
d'environnement
ou lié au nucléaire donc là il y avait
différentes tutelles qui étaient en
tension c'est vrai aussi sur un autre
sujet
qui était la préparation par exemple de
la cop21 qu'il a été davantage porté par
le ministre des Affaires étrangères
Laura fabule ce qui a fait pendule un
travail tout à fait exceptionnel qui a
été une des clés avec Florence dubiana à
ses côtés du succès de la Coop parce que
ça a été un succès après les échecs
précédents notamment celui de Copenhague
donc oui il peut y avoir des détentions
et quand vous avez des personnalités
fortes à Bercy
Michel Sapin Arnaud Montebourg et
ensuite Emmanuel Macron une personne des
efforte boulevard Saint-Germain
c'est-à-dire Ségolène Royal ça oblige et
le présent à public et le Premier
ministre avec le secrétaire général du
gouvernement à ses côtés arbitré sur les
sur les décrets sur les fondamentaux sur
les sujets les plus importants
je crois que ça n'a jamais mis en cause
ce que j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure
concernant
la volonté de préserver la filière
nucléaire les choix de la les choix en
matière de nucléaire et les choix en
matière d'environnement je veux pas
parler à sa place je me permettrai
jamais cela mais
c'est Golan Royal
souhaité préserver de la loi tous les
aspects liés au nucléaires elle aurait
souhaité que la loi soit essentiellement
consacrée à la question des énergies
renouvelables et la transition
énergétique
et que les aspects politiques liés aux
engagements du Président de la
République n'y figure pas forcément
parce que elle sentait bien en tout cas
j'ai ce souvenir que cela pouvait créer
des tensions soit avec des écologistes
soit avec la majorité sénatoriale mais
c'était difficile de parler de
transition et d'énergie sans évoquer ces
engagements qui avaient été pris d'où
les articles consacrés à 50%
[Musique]
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
parce que ça révèle une forme de
Constance
qui est redondante avec
le
Grenelle de l'environnement qui avait
lui aussi écarté la question du
nucléaire du débat
comment vous lisez ça à posteriori et
finalement en écho avec la question que
je vous posais tout à l'heure vous venez
d'affirmer que la question de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement est est une
préoccupation du gouvernement je repose
ma question je n'ai pas le sentiment que
c'était présent dans le débat public
alors ça c'est une autre question
c'est sans doute alors je
fais appel à ma mémoire
mais cette question là celle de la
provisionnement était moins importante
dans les préoccupations ça c'était
évident c'est évident qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui pour des raisons évidentes
le ce qui me frappe moi d'ailleurs d'une
manière générale
en regardant je regardais le
que sais-je sur ce sujet là écrit par
Cédric Lewandowski
c'est pas une bible pour moi mais en
tout cas il y a des éléments
intéressants et notamment il consacre
tout un chapitre
aux questions d'opinion ce qui
d'ailleurs assez frappant c'est que
l'opinion est favorable à l'énergie
nucléaire je vais sur ce sujet là pas
uniquement sur le problématique de
l'approvisionnement
majoritaire mais il y a eu
progressivement
au fond majorité en tout cas un nombre
important de Français qui exprimaient à
travers les différentes enquêtes de
pignons qui peuvent avoir leur cohérence
non pas du scepticisme là mais en tout
cas un sentiment de pas avoir d'avis sur
le sur le sujet pourquoi parce que
il y avait il y a un consensus en France
autour du nucléaire
et il y avait une forme de sûreté dans
les choix qui ont été faits
pour l'approvisionnement
en matière d'énergie d'électricité
surtout mais pas seulement et sur la
question du prix
il est évident que cela a changé
d'où les travaux que vous menez mais
d'une manière générale les choix qui
sont opérés par le gouvernement actuel
ou les débats qui ont eu lieu encore au
Sénat ces derniers jours qui me
paraissent intéressants
mais mais mais à ce moment là si pour
nous
j'allais dire de l'intérieur
c'était une priorité que nous étions
très attentifs à ce sujet là dans le
débat public ça ne
l'était pas c'est sans doute
et du coup sur la constance des
quartiers le finalement le plus clair
des
à chaque fois
et sans doute avec Jean-Louis Borloo à
l'époque alors il y a des
interprétations plutôt soit parce que de
toute façon
c'est un sujet non pas tabou mais sur
lequel est le président Sarkozy et le
président Hollande ou d'autres après
considèrent qu'il y a pas de débat à
voir à voir c'est un choix on remet pas
en cause celui de l'énergie et ouvrez
une conférence dans laquelle il y a des
il y a des
opposants et c'est tout à fait légitime
à l'énergie nucléaire n'aurait pas
beaucoup de sang j'imagine que c'était
ça mon du Grenelle de l'environnement
pour ma part si j'exprime mon avis c'est
qu'il est difficile de parler de
transition énergétique
d'environnement de sécurité en matière
d'approvisionnement
sans évoquer l'énergie nucléaire
d'autant plus si vous vous donnez des
objectifs c'est le cas de la loi
transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte
en baissant la part du nucléaire de
faire monter la part des énergies
renouvelables donc il y a forcément un
sujet puis je pense que l'opinion est
mûre j'y reviendrai en parlant de CGOS
tout à l'heure si j'ai le temps si on
donnait l'occasion pour dire non c'est
les bas méritent de la de la de la de la
transparence
du coup je reste sur une dernière
question sur la sur la question de la
construction de l'arbitrage
interministériel et
rôle du Premier ministre
au cours des auditions précédentes nous
avons entendu que le comité à l'énergie
atomique c'était très peu réuni sous le
quinquennat pendant lequel vous étiez
Premier ministre est-ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous aviez
identifié en tête choisi ou non
pas identifié
comment ça se fait alors que cette
réunion dont la loi précise qu'elle doit
se réunir une fois par an le rappel
n'arrive pas au Premier ministre
est-ce qu'il y a eu là vous me posez non
pas une colle mais il y a pas eu de
réunion sur l'autorité du Président de
la République
de oui je pense qu'il y en a eu deux oui
pour y avoir assisté à l'Elysée ça j'ai
en effet ça en mémoire mais en tout cas
ni priorité
ni élément aujourd'hui qui qui me frappe
plus particulièrement sur ce sur ce
sujet
j'en viens voulais filière industriel du
nucléaire vous avez
abordé la question du sauvetage d'arriva
qui je pense nous en conviendrons était
un dossier complexe
qu'est-ce qui m'est arrivé dans la
situation
qui conduit à la nécessité d'un
sauvetage imagine que quand on a sauvé
l'entreprise on a une vague idée de ce
qui a conduit l'entreprise dans cet état
on va dire que le nuage était accumulé
ou les difficultés
[Musique]
que nous avons constaté
une perte record de près de 5 milliards
d'euros 4,8 pour être précis
donne une société
contrôlée à 87% par l'État
un plan d'économie de 1 milliard a été
mise en oeuvre mais je réponds à votre
question et ensuite une restructuration
évidemment vous le savez
cette perte
de cette situation sont sans aucun doute
le résultat
de choix pour ne pas dire d'erreurs
stratégique
[Musique]
alors qui peut être lié aussi
au retard
dans la construction des EPR
au triplement des coûts
pour celles-ci
l'échec
d'Abu Dhabi qui a représenté un choc
bien évidemment pour la pour la pour la
filière
bon et les choix qui ont été faits aussi
que chacun connaît sur la Finlande ou
ramine
start-up liée
à l'uranium ses choix ont pesé
financièrement et structurellement
et donc il fallait
répondre
à une situation qui était extrêmement
critique
avec sans doute mais là je vois qui a
été fait et qui remonte
transformation d'Areva enfin attention
de Framatome en Areva en 2001
choix qui fait à ce moment là par Anne
Le vergeon qui a été nommé par une
Jospin que vous avez reçu que vous avez
reçu hier il y a déjà plus de
il y a plus de 20 ans
c'est un débat qui existait au sein de
la filière sur qui est capable
véritablement de
gérer les centrales nucléaires de les
construire et de les gérer
et là je pense que pendant
une bonne quinzaine d'années la filière
a vécu avec ce sujet là qu'il n'est pas
un sujet que politique si on est honnête
sujet technique et industriel qui
explique en partie peut-être pas
seulement là je m’inventure aussi les
difficultés
d'arriver sur sa capacité à mener de
front ce plan industriel et financier
l'ensemble de ces de ces sujets c'est
pour ça que
il a fallu non seulement
renflouer
de 5 milliards d'euros d'augmentation de
capital début 2016 arevas c'était des
choix financiers très très importants
qui ont aussi accompagné ce concernant
EDF
mais nous avons surtout mis en chantier
le découpage le mot est pas le bon enfin
c'est la réorganisation
d'arrêta
pareil ce fiable et nous avons dû donner
enfin nous avons également donné les
garanties nécessaires à nos partenaires
finlandais que le chantier de L3 serait
mené à terme le projet a été mise en
service l'année dernière en 2022 si je
me trompe pas nous pensions à l'époque
qu'il allait être mise en oeuvre bien
avant
pour mettre entre tenu avec mon
homologue finlandais à plusieurs
reprises c'est un sous-gene un sujet on
va l'appeler
douloureux donc
encore une fois on n'est pas de rappeler
les responsabilités des uns et des
autres mais il y a sans doute parler
tout à l'heure de découpage ministériel
de redécoupage structure ministérielle
là il y a je pense un choix plus
structurel
dans le portage EDF arrive de la de la
filière des centrales nucléaires et puis
des erreurs stratégiques ou ponctuelles
concernant des dossiers industriels qui
ont pesé lourd et enfin un marché
international qui n'a pas aidé non plus
Areva
merci dans
donc quelle action de restructuration
d'Areva
des démembrement repositionnement etc
qui clans de sauvetage d'Arena
sous votre mandat il y a également sur
le volet qui suit immédiatement le
réacteur la transformation de la vapeur
en
électricité un sujet avec la vente à
General Electric de Alstom energy est-ce
que c'est quelque chose qui vous
préoccupe à ce moment-là dans la
capacité alors que vous restructurez de
façon quasi contemporaine à Alstom
arriva de voir le
l'électrotechnicien derrière être
démembré de commission d'enquête qui a
suivi ce sujet
c'est un des sujets que nous avons eu à
traiter avec le président de la
République
immédiatement après mon arrivée et bien
sûr avec le ministre de l'économie qui
était Arnaud Montebourg à ce moment là
sujet suivi ensuite par Emmanuel Macron
dessin nominations à la fin de l'été
[Musique]
là-dessus oui il y avait évidemment la
question de l'indépendance
la souveraineté qui était qui était qui
était posé et ce que nous souhaitions
c'était le meilleur partenaire et le
choix qui a été fait était basé sur
cette idée là choisissons le meilleur
partenaire et celui qui soit le plus
compatible avec avec Alstom et c'est le
choix de j.i qui a été fait à ce à ce
moment-là et nous considérions considère
que ces choix
financiers ce qui avait été pris en
termes d'engagement d'emploi par le du
moment mais aussi concernant les
turbines
aller dans le aller dans le bon sens
en tout cas
c'était ça que j'ai c'est ça que j'avais
et que j'ai toujours à l'esprit pour
cette pour cette période
enfin sur la sur la filière je crois
qu'un dernier élément qui est marquant
dans dans votre mandat qui est le choix
du financement du mode de financement du
chantier d'inklepoint
c'est un choix là aussi qui vient en fin
qui provoque du remouche et chez EDF
avec la démission
du financier du groupe
comment est-ce que vous positionnez sur
cette stratégie qui fait porter au
groupe français le financement de ces
deux réacteurs anglais
je vous réponds entre les choix d'Areva
une quelle point une manière générale le
contexte
je veux quand même insister y compris
par rapport à l'avant des questions que
vous avez posé par rapport à Siemens
le retrait du nucléaire
de l'Allemagne se traduit aussi par un
retrait industriel notamment celui de
Siemens dans le contexte après on
reconstruit
il y avait des avocats des défenseurs
par exemple
d'un accord Alstom Siemens
longtemps porté cette idée et
Jean-Pierre Chevènement à l'époque
toujours élu sénateur de Belfort il
était il était très favorable
chose ne match pas forcément comme on
pouvait l'imaginer
mais dans le dans le retrait de
l'Allemagne du nucléaire dans la Bandon
de la filière nucléaire par l'Allemagne
il y a aussi des conséquences qui jouent
sur les EPR avec le retrait de CMS je
n'aime pas être à n'importe dans le
contexte un élément qui pèse l'autre
élément
c'est que la Commission européenne était
très attentive aussi à tous les choix
que nous faisions c'est vrai sur EDF
c'est vrai ça arrive à
Bruxelles comme on dit était était
attentif sur ces sur ces sujets là ça
pesait avec à l'époque parce que c'est
beaucoup changé
quand même tout ce qui touchait au
nucléaire au plan européen
n'était pas facile pour la France car
non seulement
l'Allemagne était sorti du nucléaire
mais l'Italie avait fait ce choix et la
Belgique depuis 2003 avait également
fait ce choix
il y avait d'autres pays l'Autriche
c'était extrêmement défavorable c'est un
contexte mais je réponds à votre
question parce que je voulais pas
oublier cette cette remarque c'est vrai
que
alors
c'est vrai que c'est à l'été 2016 que
[Musique]
l'État
donne son accord ADF pour passer le
contrat
qu'il est approuvé sur une calepoint il
est approuvé par le conseil
d'administration de DF le 28 juillet
que c'est un débat controversé en
interne
def
le CCE EDF a attaqué la décision
syndicat et notamment son syndicat CGT
énergie qui était très opposé qu'un
directeur financier a
des missionné avec fracas
et
nous avons demandé
un homme reconnu pour ses qualités dans
ce dans ce domaine là il y a des escata
nous fournir un rapport pour esquisser
les conditions du succès
ce projet avancé
depuis avec
du retard je ne sais pas si les
objectifs financiers la rentabilité
envisagée seront celles qu'on espérait
mais c'est ce choix que nous avons fait
oui dans une discussion évidemment
également avec les autorités
britanniques présents dans la République
et moi nous avons eu l'occasion de nous
entretenir
même pendant cette période qui était
difficile parce qu'il y avait référendum
sur le brexit avec David Cameron qui
était premier ministre
de du Royaume-Uni mais oui c'est ce
choix qui a été fait à ce moment-là
qui nous paraissait le plus important
pour
pour avancer et pour que DF joue ce rôle
il y avait les débats au sein d'EDF mais
c'est le choix qui était fait par le
président et par mon gouvernement pour
pour réussir cet objectif qui nous
paraissait important
en termes de crédibilité pour la France
pour l'État et pour EDF sur cette
filière
merci bien monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Premier Ministre pour ces
éléments déjà très nombreux et précis
peut-être simplement pour
épuiser au moins pour aujourd'hui le la
question des 50% de questions en rebond
à certaines à certains de vos propos
tout à l'heure vous avez dit je n'ai pas
fait moi ce choix des 50%
je me permets de vous poser la question
est-ce que vous auriez fait ce choix
[Musique]
il y a une campagne déprimée en 2011
nous avons tous participé à ce débat
avec chacun son niveau de responsabilité
j'étais pas le favori de cette primaire
mais il y avait
il y avait ce climat moi je parle pas
d'emballement
il y avait ce climat il y avait
peut-être de l'emballement et dans une
primaire d'ailleurs bon un peu une
course sur les mêmes sujets
à l'époque comme d'autres je fais des
propositions qui allaient
qui confortait ces idées là moi
responsabilités qui peuvent être les
miennes ce plan se plant ce plan
politique ce que je sais c'est que
François Hollande a été
désigné qu'il n'a pas pris
le contrat signé entre le PS le Parti
socialiste et les et les Verts pour sa
partie programmatique qu'il inscrit dans
son programme
les objectifs d'énergie renouvelable des
50% et la fermeture de façonnerie
et c'est ça qui est resté
est-ce que moi je l'aurais fait à ce
moment là sans doute parce que je pense
qu'il faut être franc sans doute
c'est vrai que j'étais au ministère de
l'Intérieur et pendant deux ans
d'ailleurs seul sujet qui me préoccupait
concernant les centrales nucléaires
c'était les intrusions
dans l'enceinte des centrales c'est un
vrai un vrai sujet évidemment avec le
directeur général de la gendarmerie
puisque c'est eux qui avaient cette
responsabilité les gendarmes cela a été
un élément de de préoccupation j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer
parce que comme ministre on a toujours
l'occasion d'aborder d'autres sujets et
je redis je crois que je le rappelais
tout à l'heure des 2012
mon soutien à la filière nucléaire parce
que dès qu'on a ouvert le capot
on s'est rendu compte que il y avait là
des enjeux qui méritaient qu'on s'adapte
à ce assez assez sujet
alors justement et ce sera la dernière
question sur ce point
je crois que chacun s'est adapté parce
que en septembre 2011 justement au
moment des primaires Ségolène Royal qui
devient votre Ministre en charge de
l'écologie
prend trois engagements en cas
d'élection l'arrêt du chantier de pair
de Flamanville la sortie sous 40 ans du
nucléaire et je cite un plan d'action
pour sortir de manière irréversible du
nucléaire
force est de constater que elle portait
position différente qui sont celles du
président de la République et de votre
gouvernement mais quand même
permettez-moi cette question un peu
naïve dans le débat interministériel et
dans les débats politiques et techniques
que vous avez est-ce que votre ministre
à l'époque plaide pour
d'autres objectifs que ceux qui sont
inscrits dans la loi des objectifs plus
contraignants pour la filière nucléaire
un plafonnement plus important est-ce
que d'autres au sein du gouvernement
vous-même sont moyennement favorables à
des objectifs de plafonnement en volume
de production ou en puissance et est-ce
que la ministre dans les discussions que
vous avez avec elle dans la droite ligne
des engagements qu'elle a pris en 2011
en cas de son élection plaide pour un
certain nombre de cibles ou d'objectifs
plus contraignantes
c'est royal mais j'ai pas en mémoire
ces déclarations précises avaient déjà
pris des engagements lors de la campagne
de 2007
qui me semble être assez cohérente avec
ses déclarations lors de la primaire de
elle avait atteint les 47% au second
tour donc on était dans un autre
contexte qui était l'élection
présidentielle
elle-même encore une fois
cela a été un sujet de débat pendant la
pendant la pendant la primaire y compris
Arnaud Montebourg sur ce sujet talent
aujourd'hui exprimer ses doutes sur
l'avenir de la filière nucléaire car il
y avait
peut-être pas partager partout et
évidemment pas surtout les bancs mais il
y avait une interrogation je dis pas un
doute mais sur la pérennité
moi-même dans cette campagne
Royal 7 donc nous
[Musique]
nous avons été interrogés moi mais je me
rappelle par exemple sur Flamanville
évidemment j'étais pas d'accord pour une
fermeture mais
la question du du type d'industrie du
type de centrale nucléaire les opère les
sémers éventuellement après
était dans le débat
comment on fait comment on les réalise
quel est le saut technologique troisième
quatrième génération que nous devons
faire
quand elle a été mais après il y a une
règle c'est la difficulté monsieur le
Président l'abordait en souriant tout à
l'heure c'est celle de la primaire c'est
que c'est un débat ouvert à tout le
monde et que la déclaration reste c'est
très présidentiel avant la
présidentielle sauf qu'il s'agit de son
camp et là on ouvre toute la boîte des
contradictions
mais le point de vue là Ségolène Royal
comme moi comme d'autres et qui ont très
loyaux c'est-à-dire
c'est François Hollande qui était élu il
avait son programme et quand elle a été
nommée ministre de l'écologie
elle n'a absolument pas abordé les
positions qui étaient les siennes en
2011 et ça n'a joué en aucun cas
vraiment j'insiste là-dessus ça n'a joué
en aucun cas sur les choix qui ont été
les nôtres ou les siens dans la
préparation de la de la loi je l'ai dit
je l'ai dit
tout ailleurs
il y avait un point mais pardon
éventuellement je leur dis non il y a
sur les
il y avait un point je l'ai pas abordé
tout à l'heure mais qui qui
était aussi dans le dans le dans le dans
le débat c'est que il y avait deux les
50%
n'étaient pas un verrou je veux assister
dans je crois monsieur le Président
votre première question sur ce sujet là
parce que chacun avait en tête que
le mot venu évidemment les questions de
sécurité énergétique serait à chaque
fois
prioritaire donc les 50% n'étaient pas
un verrou le verrou
c'était la limitation à
63,2 gigawatts
c'était là le verrou c'est là où il y a
eu le débat 50% c'est vrai ça peut être
une décision politique et qui peut
évoluer elle n'était pas fermée elle a
évolué et aujourd'hui elle est effacée
même en tout cas
par le Sénat
et d'ailleurs les retards de Flamanville
ont même rendu pour femme trompée en
disant cela
d'une certaine manière se déroule
inutile à postériori
il y avait un autre débat mais je veux
pas provoquer le pression je peux pas
provoquer c'était pas le c'est pas le
sujet non non mais en parlant de de
face à Naïm c'est que les
il y avait l'idée aussi à ce moment-là
dans le débat public et au niveau
planétaire d'ailleurs
[Musique]
c'était un choix
au fond qui était rappelé à EDF qui
était toute la filière du démantèlement
des centrales nucléaires et il y avait
aussi dans dans cette idée il fallait se
positionner sur ce sujet là alors je
sais pas s'ils veulent faire sur
fassenheim et on connaît tous la grande
difficulté technologique et technique et
financière au-delà des difficultés
sociales ou d'emploi cela peut poser sur
ce bassin vous connaissez mieux que
quiconque mais il y avait aussi cet
élément je voulais je voulais le je
voulais le rappeler
je vous remercie monsieur le premier
c'est d'ailleurs ça fait la transition
avec la question que je voulais vous
poser une question qu'on a beaucoup
abordé ici
qui est celle qui peut paraître
technique mais qui est plus générale de
la prévision de consommation
d'électricité à court moyen terme parce
que finalement on se trouve au moment de
l'accord de Paris de la préparation de
la conférence de Paris et donc de la
conception de la construction d'une
stratégie pour atteindre la sortie de la
du carbone à l'horizon 2050 et une des
options c'est évidemment
l'électrification d'une partie de nos
usages et pourtant et là c'est RTE qui
parle et on a eu ce débat d'ailleurs
avec les présidents et anciens
présidents de RTE à l'époque RTU fait un
certain nombre de scénarios prospectifs
moins robuste que le futur énergétique
mais fait un scénario prospectif assez
variés qui vont de la baisse assez
importante de la consommation électrique
à une hausse assez importante je voulais
voir votre sentiment de l'époque sur la
sur le schéma que vous avez en tête à
l'époque lorsque cette loi est votée sur
l'électrification des usages et vous
voyez l'impact je dis que vous faites la
transition puisque je pense au
plafonnement en puissance c'est
finalement si on si vous considériez à
l'époque que la production que la
consommation allait baisser alors
plafonner la production
d'électricité à partir de nucléaire
n'avait pas tout à fait la même
incidence que si vous pensiez d'une part
l'électrification des usages allaient se
poursuivre et puis d'autre part et
c'était aussi les différentes
déclarations des du gouvernement du
vôtre et des successeurs que la
réindustrialisation allait aussi amenée
la nécessité de consommer davantage
d'électricité moi je pense que c'est
cette sur le rapporteur je pense que
c'est cette idée là qui prédominait
différents scénarité évidemment élaborés
c'était d'ailleurs le rôle de RTE et
une grande confiance d'ailleurs celui
qui présidait à ses destinés à l'époque
François Brotte qui est comme
parlementaire puis à la tête de RTE
connaissait très bien c'est ces sujets
qui nous avions confiance sur le fond et
sur la sur la stratégie
il y avait d'ailleurs des parlementaires
qui étaient très attentifs à toutes ces
questions là il y avait un vrai débat
dans la majorité
la loi Bataille qui était très très
lui-même Christian Bataille était très
attentif à ces sujets je referme là la
parenthèse mais nous étions évidemment
plutôt dans cette dernière option
les sujets de réindustrialisation
étaient évidemment posée ce qui amenait
aussi la réflexion sur notre
indépendance ou notre autonomie
autonomie stratégique dans ce dans ce
dans ce domaine là mais dans les choix
qui sont faits sur la filière nucléaire
50%
dans le sauvetage
d'arriva dans les choix assignés EDF
concernant inkl point
et évidemment dans la volonté de pousser
les énergies renouvelables au maximum
il y a cet objectif
alors on peut toujours ici là où s'est
trompé sur tel ou tel point c'est tout à
fait possible mais c'est cet objectif
qui a d'ailleurs été ensuite poursuivi
donc si je suis le fil du raisonnement
il y avait dans l'idée de en
réindustrialisant et en poursuivant une
croissance économique pour notre pays
l'idée que la consommation d'électricité
en tout cas la demande d'électricité
elle est continuer à croître d'autres
parts que la production nucléaire était
plafonnée en puissance et donc
fatalement en production et donc il y
avait bien une mise enfin je pas parler
de Paris parce que ce serait inadéquat
mais une mise sur la production
d'énergie renouvelable et d'ailleurs
François broc nous a illustré de son
point de vue l'idée que cette loi et
c'est ce que vous avez redit aussi était
un objectif politique à atteindre pour
autant vous avez parlé du de la
faiblesse des études d'impact qui avait
pu présider à cette loi quel était vous
à l'époque votre regard sur sur cette
faisabilité à court terme une dizaine
d'années de développer massivement les
énergies renouvelables alors que depuis
le début des années 2000 et le lancement
des grands objectifs en matière de NR
finalement les retards c'était plutôt
accumulés
c'est incontestable ce que vous dites
c'est vrai que l'enjeu qui était le
nôtre et c'était dans l'article 1 de la
loi
de la part des renouvelables la part des
fossiles la réduction des émissions
la réduction de la consommation
énergétique
ça c'est des objectifs de la loi mais
l'idée principale c'était de diversifier
le bouquet électrique français et de
rattraper je l'ai dit au début dans mon
intervention luminaire une partie du
retard
par rapport à d'autres pays en matière
d'énergie renouvelable il y avait ce
retard
la question dont n'était pas
la hauteur de 50% mais le temps pris
pour atteindre et il était basé beaucoup
sur les énergies renouvelables
alors je me pose une question mais pour
la commission fallait-il y aller à
marche forcée
ou bien profiter au maximum du parc
existant
en préparant son renouvellement
bon donc alors c'est ce débat qui est
lieu notre optique était bien là la
deuxième mais en faisant monter le
renouvelable et au fur et à mesure je
pense que ce sont apparus encore plus
clairement ces dernières années moi je
n'étais plus responsabilité on s'est
aperçu que c'était bien plus compliqué
ou plus complexe de ce que l'on pensait
nous n'atteindrions pas en élément de
renouvelables c'est ces objectifs avec y
compris des questions dans l'opinion
posé sur l'éolien sur terre ou sur mer à
l'époque qu'est-ce qui vous faisait
penser que dans les années immédiatement
suivant immédiatement la loi 2015
le développement allait être beaucoup
plus important que les 15 dernières
années est-ce qu'il y avait des leviers
ou est-ce que vous aviez en tête des
raisons qui permettaient de penser que
on allait dans les 10 prochaines années
réussir là où pendant 15 ans on avait
manifestement pas trop ici est-ce que
sous certains nous ont parlé de ça mais
je pense à Madame Lepage notamment qui a
considéré que sans si on ne mettait pas
un coup d'arrêt au nucléaire et donc à
la perspective de son renouvellement on
ne serait pas en mesure de développer
les énergies renouvelables faisant là
une opposition que je crois dans nos
questions nous n'avions pas formulés
mais voilà je vais avoir un peu votre
regard sur sur cette regard
rétrospective sur l'idée qu'il y aurait
une concurrence entre le nucléaire et
les énergies renouvelables non c'était
cette ça n'était pas cette option il y
avait sans doute l'idée chez certains
n'ont pas par l'arrêt du nucléaire en
l'occurrence mais en se donnant cet
objectif de 50% d'atteindre et de
libérer par une forme de volontarisme
bien français cette cette objective et
en essayant de pousser il y a eu de
nombreuses réunions de nombreuses
rencontres
avec tous les acteurs du renouvelable de
pousser au maximum ces sujets là mais il
est évident que je sais pas dans le
domaine du solaire enfin du
photovoltaïque on sait très vite
retrouver avec le même problème que le
passé c'est-à-dire la capacité de
production
qui avait été totalement
mise en cause et qui était parti vers la
Chine donc c'est surtout ces sujets là
je pense que nous n'avions pas
les outils pour conforter l'objectif
mais que l'idée était de se les donner
au fur et à mesure bien évidemment pour
les ministres que j'étais moi je me
dérobe qu'une responsabilité je me suis
exprimé de nombreuses fois sur ce sujet
là vous fait grâce de mes déclarations
et encore une fois parce qu'il y avait
aussi le rendez-vous de la Coop 21 mais
il y a eu de nombreuses rencontres de
nombreuses réunions à tous les acteurs
économiques industriels avec des
entreprises grandes petites des
partenaires étrangers et européens
notamment pour atteindre ces objectifs
là l'Union européenne en tout cas la
commission était évidemment une forme de
de soutien peut-être la difficulté était
sous-estimée sur la capacité à atteindre
cette objectif mais d'ailleurs les
chiffres montrent que ça dépend des
secteurs là on les atteint dans d'autres
secteurs non
merci je reviens quelques dernières
questions sur nos entreprises françaises
peut-être quand même une sur EDF à votre
arrivée aux responsabilités j'imagine
que vous avez des échanges avec les
responsables d'EDF puisque les sujets
sont assez stratégiques
une double question enfin une question
générale sur l'état à votre sens de
l'entreprise tel que telle que vous la
trouvez à votre arrivée à Matignon avec
deux branches de questions à la fois sur
le sur le Pr
plusieurs reports ont lieu sous le
quinquennat pendant lequel vous avez été
Premier ministre en particulier en 2015
et qu'un report assez conséquent et puis
ensuite le rapport fols qui permettra de
déterminer quelles sont les différentes
causes de retard mais je pense qu'à
l'époque vous pouviez déjà en avoir une
certaine vision en tout cas j'ai fait
j'ai une qu'on vous a fourni des
explications et puis sur le grand
carénage parce que finalement dès 2010
le rapport Roussely prévoyait
la plupart de ces de ces éléments et on
peut s'interroger va vous arriver au
moment où vous activez ce vous permettez
à ce à ce plan d'être lancé est-ce que
vous avez aussi l'impression est-ce que
vous avez pu avoir l'impression que des
retards avaient été pris que la gestion
aurait pu être plus rapide et que
l'anticipation aurait pu être plus
importante ce qui aurait pu s'en faire
de science-fiction puisqu'on s'astreint
à être le plus rigoureux possible ici
aurait pu éviter la juxtaposition de
problèmes qu'on a connu ces derniers
mois
sur l'état
moi c'est
un patriote il y aura un publicain et je
crois beaucoup dans ces grandes
entreprises qui font de la colonne
vertébrale de ce qu'est de ce qu'elle
est à français et comme la comme cette
nation s'est construite par l'État
j'y suis évidemment très attentif et
notamment à ceux qui la dirigent
et EDF a eu la chance d'avoir
des présidents je crois de très grande
qualité qui se sont succédés
et donc j'ai eu l'occasion de les
rencontrer un ancien qui parce qu'il
avait réalisé un rapport à la demande du
président Nicolas Sarkozy François
Michelin mais je connaissais depuis
longtemps qui est venu souvent me
rencontrer quand j'étais à Matignon
[Musique]
qui a leur disparu il y a quelques jours
en repoglio un homme de qualité se
posait la question de son renouvellement
c'est le choix qui ont été fait et j'en
suis solidaire bien sûr par par le chef
de l'État
et le président Lévy aussi
donc il y avait une confiance mais le
sentiment qui est d'ailleurs le même
fuser une expression
un peu générale mais EDF était à la
croisée des chemins et c'est ce
sentiment que j'avais
et c'est vrai pour la filière je reviens
pas sûr arrive
EDF était confronté les problèmes
financiers qu'il a fallu résoudre
et il est évident que
le retard pris sur Flamanville et la
nécessité de monter en puissance par
rapport aux grandes carénages
venait un moment
pouvait être
représenter une mise en cause des
objectifs que j'ai rappelé de la loi de
2015 y compris par rapport à la
fermeture de fassenheim
et donc du coup ce n'est pas une
question c'était pas le sens de vos
questions politiques c'est une question
technique technologique de savoir-faire
c'est un défi pour EDF pas uniquement
quand j'étais Premier ministre mais pour
aujourd'hui et pour demain parce que
c'est son savoir-faire il y a des à tous
les niveaux de l'entreprise il y a des
gens du très grande qualité mais cette
entreprise doit doit être capable
d'atteindre les objectifs
qu'elle s'assigne ou qu'on lui assigne
après les problèmes liés aussi aux
normes de sécurité concernant
Flamanville ils sont là mais on ne peut
que les constater et sur
le programme de grands carénage
qui était à des premiers sujets que j'ai
abordé avec avec Jean Bernard
Lévy qui a été
adopté par le Conseil administration de
janvier 2015 de l'entreprise mise en
oeuvre progressivement si la trajectoire
financière a été respectée le
déploiement du programme de par
l'ampleur des travaux à réaliser
notamment lors des visites décennales a
conduit et le moindre disponibilité du
parc nucléaire donc
quel que soit le président de la
République quel que soit le gouvernement
ils doivent être très attentifs à la
situation d'EDF à sa capacité à se
réformer en interne parce que nous avons
besoin que ces grandes entreprises dur
mais aussi se reforme et s'adapte et
soit capable également sans que celle-ci
soit
décalé par rapport à la réalité qu'elle
s'adapte aussi à la commande à la
commande
publique donc
ce plan qui était également lié au
retour d'expérience de de Fukushima
doit être mise en oeuvre mais Vasseur t
bien sûr à d'autres débats sur le
prolongement de l'âge des centrales
nucléaires
40-6080
mais en rassurant le politique parce que
c'est une manière aussi de rassurer
l'opinion
mais justement vous avez évoqué les
difficultés financières de DF
effectivement les présidents anciens
présidents d'EDF ont évoqué les anciens
présidents n'ont mentionné que deux
causes
sous le contrôle de président des autres
membres de la commission d'enquête que
sont les prix qui auraient les tarifs
qui auraient été trop bas pour
supporter les pour supporter les
investissements importants et puis la
reine d'abord je veux bien votre
appréciation sur ces deux points et
peut-être aussi d'appréciation que vous
avez à l'époque est-ce que les
présidents dans le coup le président
d'EDF dans le cadre des entretiens qu'il
a avec vous ou vous administrations vous
feront monter des éléments qui
pourraient faire penser qu'il n'y a pas
uniquement une question de prix et de
tarif à Rennes qui permettraient
d'expliquer certaines difficultés
financières de DF dans les dernières
années
[Musique]
que sur l'arène
le sujet préoccupation exprimée
longuement devant votre commission par
Jean-Bernard Lévy
moi je n'ai pas souvenir je connaissais
les tensions
et je n'ai pas souvenir que que ce sujet
là soit venu
à Matignon comme un élément qui
obligeait à des à des arbitrages mais
qu'il y avait une tension pour la
définir pour définir ce rapport cette
c'est incontestable en revanche on en
parlera beaucoup plus longuement que moi
oui il y a eu sur la question du prix
beaucoup de dialogues beaucoup de
discussions entre le président de DF et
la ministre qui avait une préoccupation
qu'on peut comprendre à l'aune de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui qui était le
consommateur c'était c'était un vrai
sujet et dans les arbitrages dans le
temps parce que en plus il fallait être
attentif à la Commission européenne et
au Conseil d'État en tout cas aux
autorités juridiques
le président de la République moi-même
avons essayé de trouver à chaque fois un
chemin de crête dans les dans les
arbitrages qui cherchent à concilier
n'ont pas la demande de la ministre sa
préoccupation qui me paraissait légitime
et les attentes financières d'EDF encore
une fois surtout ces sujets là ça ne
veut pas dire pour autant que c'est pas
des
des changements structurels lesquels je
ne sais pas qui s'impose pour les pour
cette grande entreprise qui est
je vous remercie monsieur le Premier
ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur maisonnet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre m'a première question
est simple mais inévitable sur la
question de la fermeture de la centrale
de Fessenheim dans la mesure où je n'ai
toujours pas compris à travers vos
premières réponses pourquoi pourquoi
avoir laissé la porte ouverte à la
fermeture d'un site qui était
selon vos propres mots en bon état de
fonctionnement qui avait une durée de
vie encore intéressante qu'est-ce qui
pouvait le justifier techniquement au
moment de l'accord avec les Verts il
doit bien y avoir des éléments autres
électoraux scientifiques donc j'entends
qui vous permettait de vous rejoindre
sur ce point de l'accord donc quels
sont-ils et si c'était aujourd'hui à
refaire mais triez-vous un terme au
processus de fermeture de cette centrale
prenant une réduction de la part du
nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité vous avez rappelé à de
nombreuses reprises que l'objectif était
de passer sous la barre des 50% de
nucléaire à l'horizon 2025 nous sommes
en 2023 à 2 ans de la date que vous
préconisiez qu'elle regarde portez-vous
sur la non-réalisation de ces objectifs
vous dites aujourd'hui que personne au
gouvernement ne croyait réellement à ses
50% et à la fermeture d'autres réacteurs
d'ici 2025 alors pourquoi avez-vous
vous-même
usé de ces éléments de communication
le nucléaire que le gouvernement soit
désormais relancé souffre d'une pénurie
de main d'oeuvre et de la perte de
savoir-faire en cause l'annonce de la
fermeture d'une partie de nos centrales
nucléaires et le manque d'investissement
des dernières années
aujourd'hui avez-vous le regret de ne
pas avoir lancé de nouveau réacteurs de
recherche de n'avoir lancé la
construction d'aucune nouvelle centrale
de ne pas avoir poussé les jeunes à
s'orienter vers ces métiers comment vous
positionnez-vous aujourd'hui sur la
relance du nucléaire français
si vous soutenez aujourd'hui un tel
projet comment expliquer vous ne pas
l'avoir plus fait à l'époque
vous avez évoqué à plusieurs reprises
l'accident de Fukushima nombre de
spécialistes disent qu'un tel accident
ne pouvait et ne pourrait pas survenir
dans les centrales françaises en raison
de leur dispositif de sécurité
disposiez-vous à l'époque d'éléments
scientifiques sérieux et probants pour
penser que ce risque était transposable
à la France
je le redis vous partagiez l'objectif
50% nucléaire à l'horizon 2025 dans
notre production d'électricité le reste
devait être couvert par les EnR on sait
que le nucléaire s'il présente des
avantages comparatifs remarquables n'est
pas pilotable rapidement sa production
ne peut pas fluctuer d'une heure à
l'autre et s'adapter au rythme des
énergies intermittentes la question que
je souhaite donc vous poser la suivante
quelles énergies auriez-vous compté
utiliser les jours où le vent et le
soleil se serait fait plus rare
imaginez-vous réellement développer des
énergies intermittentes sans relancer
des centrales à gaz ou à charbon
comme le fond d'ailleurs
nos voisins allemands si oui
pourriez-vous nous dire ce qui vous
permettait de le penser
en refusant de réinvestir dans notre
parc national tout en évitant de lancer
de grands projets de recherche vous avez
contribué à l'affaiblissement de notre
industrie nucléaire tout jugement de
valeur mise à part nous étions pourtant
l'un des pays les plus avancés dans la
maîtrise de l'atome alors que nous
perdions nos savoir-faire et prenions du
retard vous avez choisi d'investir dans
les renouvelables
ne regrettez-vous pas d'avoir investi
des dizaines de milliards d'euros dans
des ENR dans la quasi-totalité fabriquée
par des multinationales étrangères
pourquoi ne pas avoir mis en place les
conditions du développement d'une
industrie nationale des énergies
renouvelables et ne trouvez pas vous pas
dommage que la transition énergétique
que vous appelez de vos vœux ne
s'appuient presque exclusivement que sur
des industries étrangères alors que nous
étions pratiquement leader mondial dans
le dans le nucléaire voilà Monsieur le
Premier Ministre ça fait beaucoup de
questions pour lesquelles on peut
attendre des réponses merci
sans aucun doute
[Musique]
que par les choix que nous avons fait
nous ayons affaibli nous la volonté
après l'autre c'est un débat plus
politique logique et normale dans cet
enceinte
normalement le cœur de la démocratie
nous ayons affaibli ou eu la volonté
d'affaiblir j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure
qu'au contraire
l'objectif était de soutenir de
renforcer
cette filière
tous mes discours mes déclarations La
Teste mais aussi nos actes
c'est vrai je l'ai rappelé tout à
l'heure
concernant le choix de sur Areva
l'idée était de sauver là
un des fleurons en tout cas une filière
très importante c'était douloureux parce
que ça s'est traduit aussi par des
pertes d'emploi
et
pour EDF
[Musique]
deuxièmement le choix de fasenheim est
un choix à la fois politique
je le rappelais tout à l'heure il est
basé sur le fait que c'est la plus
ancienne mais avec des acteurs
qui étaient en très bon état qui avait
été renouvelé la SN l'avait rappelé
je ne vais pas affirmer le contraire il
y a eu même un débat sur est-ce qu'il
est sur une zone inondable etc des
sujets techniques il y avait quand le
choix a été fait aussi
la tente de nos amis allemands enfin
n'étaient pas évidemment
prescriptible c'est pas elle c'est pas
l'Allemagne qui pouvait nous imposer un
choix mais c'est ce choix qui a été fait
un choix politique partant de la
centrale la plus la plus ancienne
je ne répondrai pas la question est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui je le refais ou pas
pourquoi parce que moi je veux être
honnête avec vous je vais vous dire la
vérité de ce que j'ai fait
hier et donc dans ce que j'ai fait hier
dans mes dans mon action et dans mes
déclarations comme premier ministre je
n'ai rien fait pour éviter ce choix il a
été accompagné d’ailleurs un délégué
interministériel pour préparer la
fermeture de fassenheim a été mis en
place au début du quinquennat
je n'étais que j'étais ministre de
l'Intérieur donc j'étais pas concerné
par ces sujets là et donc là aujourd'hui
je
j'ai plus que une responsabilité mais si
je vous disais bon j'aurais fait
autrement tout ça n'a aucun sens
sur la relance
ou la construction de nouvelles
centrales
pardon mais nous attendions l'ouverture
de flamant ville et aussi en Finlande
pour constater la capacité de cette
nouvelle génération en tout cas de ces
nouveaux réacteurs
tous les tous les acteurs de la filière
partager cette idée
et c'est très important et moi j'insiste
là-dessus que Flamanville ouvre c'est
très important pour la filière là c'est
un élément de la confiance
ni vous ni moins ni pour rien c'est lié
non plus il y a des questions politiques
c'est réglé François Hollande n'a pas
arrêté le projet en 2012
il faut qu'il réussisse pour redonner
confiance dans
[Musique]
ce domaine là
en 2016 j'ai signé deux lettres de
mission
à Louis Gauthier qui était secrétaire
général
de la défense de la sécurité nationale
à Louis Gauthier et au GDSN parce que il
y avait les questions liées à notre
sécurité à notre défense nationale
en matière de dissuasion une première
pour examiner les problèmes de de
prolifération de nos proliférations pour
être précis une pour examiner la
pertinence pour la France de se
positionner sur le marché des SMS
qui n'est ni une idée du président
Macron ni du Premier ministre Valls mais
qui viennent très loin de la fin des
années 90
donc une pour examiner la pertinence
pour la France de se positionner sur le
marché des sémers et une pour faire une
proposition de choix préférentiel de
technologie car il y avait à l'époque
plusieurs options sur la table et à
partir de là ce qu'on appelle l'équipe
de France
du SMR se met en marche derrière EDF sur
la base design conçu par le spécialiste
des petits
réacteurs nucléaires techniques atomes
et aujourd'hui le projet j'imagine ces
évolutions technologiques que je ne
connais pas et toujours activement
soutenu et c'est un exemple je veux
insister là-dessus parce qu'il y a eu
des échecs par le passé celui d'Abou
Dhabi sur lequel j'insiste
qui était malheureusement important pour
le pour le moral le climat de notre
filière c'est un exemple donc de
collaboration entre les acteurs français
EDF CEA technique atomes Framatome et
d'autres et donc j'ai relancé
ou en tout cas c'est sous le quinquennat
François Hollande que ce programme qui
était moribond a été a été relancé je
pense cet exemple pour vous dire que 1
il fallait attendre il faut attendre
c'est important pour la filière c'est
important pour l'export l'ouverture de
de Flamanville il fallait attendre
l'ouverture en Finlande quel point
ensuite
et pour la filière et à l'export et
ensuite il y a eu la relance des
SMR et donc et puis je vais le répondre
au groupe et à la question m'avait posée
sur face à Naïm et sur
et sur et sur l'avenir je partage
vraiment
le choix qui a été fait ou annoncé
plutôt par le Président de la République
il y a il y a un an nous voit parce que
c'est Manuel Macron c'est pas le sujet
mais parce que ça me paraît un choix
important pour le pour le pays et c'est
sur la base de ce discours qu'on doit
construire un consensus
national parce que j'ai le sentiment que
les difficultés que on a eu même si moi
je veux pas les exagérer qu'on a eu sur
le parc nucléaire sur des difficultés
techniques franchement les problèmes
d'érosion ou hier d'autres types de
problèmes que nous avons connus et que
j'ai rappelé sur lequel je n'aurai pas
sont pas dû à des choix politiques
qui sont par rapport à une matière moi
j'en suis pas le spécialiste ma
passionné de m'y pencher pendant que
j'étais au gouvernement avant ou après
aussi on entend de mes collaborateurs
spécialistes sur ces sujets là mais
c'est des sujets qui sont
techniquesment extrêmement complexes
et on apprend qui aurait pu imaginer le
retard pris par le père de Flamanville
et je m'en désole mais pas pour accuser
quelqu'un
parce que cessé de réalité à laquelle
nous faisons face donc
mais ce que j'espère surtout ce qui me
paraît le plus important c'est que
toutes ces équipes France que j'ai
rappelé soit au rendez-vous sur les
choix de demain le président de la
République peut définir un
cap mais ce qui a marché dans les années
50-60 et 70 et 80 c'est que derrière
c'est là où peut-être vous avez raison
nous avons sans doute perdu de la
capacité dans ce domaine-là mais
l'attribuer mon seul gouvernement au
gouvernement François Hollande serait
trop c'est très c'est trop c'est trop
c'est trop rapide je pense qu'il y a eu
des difficultés qui viennent d'assez
loin
mais le discours
du président de la République doit
réarmer l'ensemble de la filière mais il
faut que d'un point de vue technologique
même pas les questions financières ils
sont déjà colossales colossales
doit être capable de les atteindre et ça
je c'est là où on a un rendez-vous avec
avec l'histoire très très importante
Fukushima non vous avez raison c'est un
bien les centrales nucléaires en France
qui peuvent connaître à certains de
risques notamment en termes
d'inondations nous le savons
l'agence eveille
nous avons tous que l'accident de
Fukushima
dû un tsunami il n'est pas dû au risque
même sur la centrale nucléaire mais
c'est un fait moi je
voulais dire la France n'a pas fait ce
choix mais
je sais pas moi j'ai l'impression que
jusqu'à maintenant personne ne considère
ou la considéré en gala Merkel son
gouvernement et l'Allemagne comme des
gens qui prennent des décisions légères
en désaccord je pense que c'est un choix
qui peut-être aujourd'hui aurait dû être
révisé du fait de la dépendance
au gaz et au pétrole russe mais ils ont
fait ce choix
donc
voilà
le choix qui a été fait en 2012 c'est en
effet la réduction de la part du
nucléaire dans la production électrique
le choix du renouvelable la confirmation
évidemment de le père de flamantsville
une politique à l'export une quelpod la
Finlande la Chine aussi des discussions
avec le Japon qui a ensuite relancé un
choix qui a été fait aussi c'est à
l'époque le Premier ministre AB
des partenariats une concurrence qui
commençait à se faire sentir en Europe
pays comme la République tchèque c'est
le choix du nucléaire donc à quel type
de partenaire la Chine des pays
européens
dans un climat défavorable au niveau de
la Commission européenne
on fait le choix nous de conforter cette
cette filière et donc c'est le rôle de
la Commission donc je vais pas le juger
mais d'une certaine manière les débats
sur le passé moi ne m'intéresse que dans
un seul domaine pas pour mettre en cause
telle ou tel politique parce que si on
rentre là-dedans je trouvera tous des
arguments mais comment on fait pour être
les mieux armés pour pour l'avenir c'est
ça qui m'intéresse je vous remercie de
vos questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le Premier
ministre monsieur Dubois
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Premier Ministre j'aurais deux
questions vous avez évoqué au niveau de
la loi de transition énergétique de vos
choix et des problématiques qui
faisaient sur les retards sur les EnR
et notamment vous avez parlé du
renouvellement des concessions
hydroélectriques
qui était connu donc depuis 2011 avec
une pression donc de l'Union européenne
donc depuis 2011 pourquoi pendant
l'ensemble de de votre exercice à
Matignon
aucune décision et et pourquoi ensuite
sur je reviendrai sur le pilotage de
l'arène vous avez dit que tout à l'heure
avec des fortes personnalités dans
différents ministères sous votre sous le
gouvernement donc sous votre
gouvernement il vous fallait faire des
arbitrages notamment sur les décrets
Jean-Louis Borloo nous a bien spécifié
que la reine se devait d'être pilotée
notamment sur deux points à la fois sur
les volumes donc qui était de 100
terawatts et jusqu'à donc 150 terwatts à
l'horizon 2020
avec donc une production à ce moment-là
de 400 Tera what
on savait et vous saviez donc avec les
les arrêts de réacteur sous maintenant
que ça pouvait être piloté et à la fois
sur la tarification Monsieur Philippe de
Ladoucette de la creux nous dit que en
2014 donc son rapport
demande une évaluation de la
tarification
également et
il nous dit que depuis 2014 donc aucun
décret ce qui est vrai n'est sorti sur
cette tarification alors pourquoi vous
avez pas fait l'arbitrage
et sur cette deuxième question très
honnêtement je suis incapable de vous
répondre
le rôle du Premier ministre est vaste
les épaules sont larges
c'est vrai que les décrets sont préparés
par le scrutateur général du
gouvernement en lien avec le cabinet du
Premier ministre et le cabinet des
ministres
concernés
mais les arbitrages concernant la reine
ne sont pratiquement jamais
certains points sont remontés mais sur
ces questions de tarification du niveau
des tarawatts ne sont pas montés en
termes de pilotage sont pas montés à mon
niveau et à mon avis ils sont pas
comptés au niveau du président de la
République non plus je pense que c'est
Golan Royal il reviendra dans dans
ce l'audition
peuvent remonter les arbitrages plus
cruciaux plus stratégiques ou de ou de
nomination mais j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure que de mémoire
moi souvenir qu'on soit remonté les
tensions qui pouvaient exister entre EDF
et la reine même si Jean Bernard Lévy a
dû l'évoquer avec moi donc honnêtement
je vais regarder suite à votre question
et s'il le faut je manquerai pas de vous
écrire monsieur le monsieur le Président
sur ce sujet là mais je suis obligé là
vraiment d'aller consulter les les le
passé même si j'essayais de me préparer
au mieux à toutes les à toutes les
questions sur le premier sujet
concernant les concessions
hydrauliques je pense que la réponse est
dans dans ce que je dis tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que nous avons été
notamment la ministre mais elle vous
répondra aussi sur ce point-là par de
Ségolène Royal l'ancien ministre
l'idée était de
de d'être attentif
là une forme d'indépendance par rapport
à ce que demandait la Commission
européenne
et donc du coup on a dû gagner du temps
mais interrogez là et je vais je vais
regarder ça aussi de mon côté pour
l'alerté et peut-être vous apporter une
réponse plus précise
mais vous êtes un fin spécialisé des
questions pas moi
j'aurai une question pour revenir sur
des enjeux plus politiques
et partager avec vous un sentiment qui
qui se retrouve dans l'accord électoral
qui est celui
enfin sur l'accord politique qui est
celui
constitue entre le Parti socialiste et
les Verts
c'est que les opposants à la filière
nucléaire ont finalement depuis les
années 90
une stratégie assez ciblée sur des
éléments du cycle complet
super super Phénix à la fin des années
perspective de la fermeture du cycle
cela obtenu
deux éléments
la définition d'une durée de vie
pour les centrales par la fermeture de
Fessenheim parce que c'est pas c'est la
centrale la plus vieille qu'on ferme
c'est pas la plus dangereuse c'est la
plus vieille et on crée un précédent
définissant une forme d'âge standard de
l'arrêt et puis le dernier élément et
vous l'avez abordé dans votre propre
limitaire qui est de s'attaquer
aussi que combustible et ce qui ce qu'il
en reste avec la filière MOX
qui est pourtant finalement une une
vision plutôt vertueuse de l'économie de
matière du recyclage enfin tout ce qu'on
entend dans tous les domaines
nécessaires à l'économie circulaire mais
qui ne serait pas valable pour le
nucléaire
donc
en réalité en écartant cette proposition
du deal comme ça se dit maintenant
de l'accord politique vous semblez
écarter cette stratégie des écologistes
mais pour autant vous prenez celle sur
la définition d'un âge standard de
fermeture des réacteurs
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
très bonne question les autres étaient
excellentes aussi
ça lui rapporteur et évidemment
[Musique]
mais au fond ça d'abord cela renvoie
Odile n'est pas un accord politique
entre le PS dans la promesse critère a
été Martine Aubry et les écologistes
les éléments importants c'était le
nombre de circonscriptions et l'autre
c'était l'accord programmatique
François Hollande qui était conscient je
crois des enjeux de la filière nucléaire
j'en suis certain
à garder les 50%, je m'en suis déjà
expliqué
et il est vrai que la fermeture de
fasanaïm je l'ai dit tout là il me
repose pas sur des éléments objectifs
même si encore une fois c'est en effet
la plus ancienne mais
pas la plus dangereuse en tout cas pas
celle qui n'en aucune qui est la plus
dangereuse mais celle qui pose des
problèmes qui auraient posé des points
de techniques suite aux travaux moi
quand je les visitais il y avait un
réacteur qui fonctionnait et l'autre qui
était précisément en travaux ou
rénovation
[Musique]
mais qui est basé sur un objectif voilà
il y a une centrale nucléaire qui est
fermée
fermé pour créer ce cercle vertueux pour
les énergies renouvelables et peut-être
aussi pour ouvrir une vraie filière sur
le démantèlement des centrales en
laissant ouvert
la question de l'âge de la durée et j'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure que nous avons
écarté systématiquement au cours du
quinquennat ou de la législature tout
débat sur la question de la durée alors
vous pouvez dire il y a une
contradiction vous fermez la plus la
plus la plus ancienne alors qu'elle est
en bon état mais vous ne considérez rien
sur la question de l'âge ou de la durée
pour les autres c'est vrai mais d'un
côté il y en a une le côté il y a tous
les autres et là il y a pas de choix qui
est fait sur sur l'âge et au contraire
pour confirmer cette volonté de ne pas
rentrer dans ce dans ce dans ce dans
cette voie là il y a le plan de grand
carénage qui reçoit notre soutien absolu
donc par là
parce que le débat est et
clair donc il y a peut-être des
contradictions politiques vous les
relevés
mais sur les autres choix qui sont qui
sont faits
sur le
sur le MOX je l'ai rappelé tout à
l'heure il n'y a pas eu
au contraire une volonté de conforter ce
le développement
du MOX comment ça se forme unise parce
que aujourd'hui le MOX la filière est
pas en pleine forme qui a un certain
nombre de décisions mode sur la
modernisation de la filière qui n'ont
pas été prise non parce que les c'est
vrai que la loi de 2015 de ce point de
vue là ne prend aucune décision il n'y a
aucun élément là-dessus elle renvoie
plutôt aux travaux de planification qui
existait sur ce
sujet
et tous les études ce qu'on appelle
moxas du du palier 1300 MW était en
cours à l'époque et on a toujours voulu
maintenir le moxissage précisément donc
il y a pas de de
moi en regardant pour préparer cette
audition je rappelais que on me
rappelait que pour mémoire dans
l'histoire de la filière l'idée était
que les combustibles
usagers
uranium ou plutonium pouvait être
recyclés dans les surgénateurs à notre
trop rapide
qu'aux plan industriel la filière
précisément et RNR c'est c'est avéré
plutôt comme un échec relatif et que dès
les années 80 on avait enclenché le
frein sur ce développement donc il y
avait un problème de débouché pour les
combustibles
usagés
et qu'à partir de ce moment-là de le
développement du MOX avait été avait été
lancé avec l'usine Médoc de de Marcoule
voilà mais aucun choix négatif au-delà
des difficultés techniques
technologiques
sur cette filière mais aucun choix
évidemment ne remettait en cause le max
donc ça c'est
c'est affirmé de deux manières un nom
clair en octobre novembre 2011 quand
certains sont revenus à la charge et
[Musique]
dans les choix qui ont été faits par le
gouvernement
vous avez fait il doit avoir très
intéressant en rappelant au fond que le
position au nucléaire se manifeste ou se
manifester de deux manières
soit un message clair faut fermer
le choix de des écologistes
qu'on peut comprendre un
philosophiquement
en France ou en Allemagne
ma génération a grandi en voyant passer
des Dianes ou des ou des deux chevaux
avec le nou nucléaire qui venait de
Suisse de Belgique d'Allemagne
mais bon moi j'ai vécu avec ça je l'ai
routes de vacances
oui sur les Volkswagen à l'époque donc
c'est un choix nette ou en s'attaquant
de manière plus plus intelligente plus
pernicieuse pour nous dire laisse le
choix du vocabulaire à des éléments
super Phénix hier des choix ça c'est moi
je peux pas rentrer dans ce débat même
si à l'époque j'étais son conseiller
chargé de la communication de la presse
enfin j'avais pas voix au chapitre
heureusement sur ces sur ces sur ces
sujets là
moi j'ai le sentiment aujourd'hui j'ai
le sentiment les choses ont changé quand
même assez radicalement
que quand je vois la position des verres
des gwenen au sein du gouvernement sur
d'autres questions parce que l'ouverture
ne se pose pas enfin sur les centrales à
charbon
tels qui se posent les choix que la
Belgique vient de faire même si un
objectif de retarder la fermeture le
choix même en France
qui cette imposée 7 pouces là profite de
votre question que
il y a eu un autre débat parce que là
c'est d'autres éléments de la filière
qui est si géo
parce que
qui a été poussé autant que possible
pendant cette période il répond aussi à
deux questions tout à l'heure la loi de
prévoyait qu'un texte législatif
caractérise la notion de réversibilité
et définissent une phase industrielle
pilote afin qu'on puisse être donné par
décret l'autorisation d'exploiter
on l'a mis dans la loi de transition de
[Musique]
puis l'article a été mis finalement dans
la loi Macron des questions économiques
doutes de la même année qui était annulé
par le Conseil constitutionnel qui la
considérait comme un cavalier et
finalement on a utilisé une PLPL sur
proposition de Gérard Longuet
un local assez concerné par le projet
et
la demande d'autorisation de création de
Cigéo a d'ailleurs été déposé là je
crois
récemment par parlanta c'était un
élément
[Musique]
assez fondamental de la très importante
de la de la de la filière dans dans les
remises en cause de la filière
évidemment l'usine de La Hague était un
des points un des points symboliques je
crois qu'on vous en a parlé pas
forcément de manière positive ces
derniers ces derniers temps devant la
commission donc
l'idée était vraiment de préserver tous
les éléments de de la de la de la
filière et au fond les les événements
nous ont donné plutôt raison je fais une
pirouette parce que je considère qu'il y
a aucun élément fondamental qui a été
mis en cause qui ne permettent pas
demain de relancer en force cette
filière sinon encore une fois les sauts
les sauts technologiques pour moi est
vraiment le seul élément préoccupant
avec évidemment les investissements
financiers nécessaires mais s'il y a
cette volonté politique et cette
capacité à réaliser des stocks
technologiques nous sommes capables
d'aller au-delà je dois dire que
sur la durée de vie je ne suis pas un
spécialiste ces questions là mais
reconnaissons que on a commencé avec 35
ou 40 ans je répète que je dis tout à
l'heure et aujourd'hui on est sur l'idée
de 80 c'est
je vois très important que l'opinion
publique soit en permanence etc
et convaincu que la SN doit aider pour
que ni aucun doute sur le fait qu'on
prolonge et qu'on est capable de
prolonger les Américains mais
d'autres éléments que les nôtres
d'analyse enfin ils sont quand même très
attentifs à la sécurité eux ils ont eu
un accident nucléaire et qui n'a rien à
voir avec le Japon et qui n'a rien à
voir avec le dysfonctionnement de
Tchernobyl c'est un grand pays
industriel
pour expliquer pourquoi on a cette
capacité de prolonger jusqu'à 80
un aliment qui parait important pour
qu'on garde en effet tous les éléments
de la du processus
peut-être qu'il y a saut technologique
bien sûr
simplement pour partager du coup sur la
question de la filière du démantèlement
finalement qui était une des
préoccupations j'aime pas trop
m'exprimer sur Facebook dans cette
commission pour essayer de rendre un peu
de crédibilité à cette commission
mais au-delà de la préservation de la
filière que vous avez abordé dans cette
tentative de casser quelques briques de
ce qui tient ensemble et seulement parce
qu'il y a toutes les briques
la filière du démantèlement elle reste à
construire encore faut-il ne passer
opposer et on a aujourd'hui un combat
qui est en train de s'installer par je
pense ceux qui sont anti-nucléaires sont
présager de la
des raisons pour lesquelles le sont et
on les respectant
c'est d'empêcher la constitution de
cette filière
et ceux de longue date
puisqu'on a notamment dans notre PNG mdr
donc l'entre-plan national de gestion
des déchets et matières radioactives qui
est régulièrement soumis à débat des
éléments qui empêchent la constitution
de cette filière je pense notamment à la
qualification de ce qu'est un déchet
nucléaire dans la perspective d'un
éventuellement et pour suivre de près le
démantèlement de Fessenheim c'est pas
gagné pour des raisons réglementaires et
politiques de réussir à construire en
France une filière du démantèlement
merci beaucoup Monsieur
le Premier Ministre pour
ces éléments pour le temps que vous nous
avez consacré pour la préparation qui a
été la vôtre de notre entretien je crois
que c'est une constante dans les
auditions que nous faisons c'est que les
auditions précédentes ont été écoutées
et que les auditions courantes sont
préparés donc merci beaucoup pour
le respect que vous avez formulé à
l'endroit du travail du Parlement c'est
moi merci beaucoup merci à vous